the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
dubious novelties and sensational saves
ruled the day at the super bed chess
classic in romania with both leaders
drawing their games local hero bogdan
dayoff stole the spotlight in front of
delighted fans but the happiest man in
the hall was lavonne aronian who was
able to save his game against alareza
farrugia in a dramatic stalemate the
clocks are set and the piece is placed
day four of exciting chess coming up
next
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome everybody to day four of the
2022 superbad chess classic the
inaugural stop of the grand chess tour
behind me is the royal palace a
monumental building situated in the
heart of bucharest while that was the
home of ancient kings of history we have
the present kings of the board ready to
battle it all out let's go to the studio
and start today's action with yasser
peter and alejandra
beautiful springtime shots of booker
estromania as we welcome you to our
coverage of the super bed chess classic
the first event of the 2022 grand chess
tour
hi i'm peter swiddler and with me is the
assassin how are you doing i'm doing
pine peter it's a pleasure as always to
be with you here
as well as alejandro hello everyone and
welcome to our live coverage of the
bucharest super bet
grand chess tour tournament
the first two rounds will go down as
being thrilling rounds with high quality
games but round three had two incredible
spills
specifically richard rapport on move 40
and ali riza farouja who failed to win
what were winning games take us through
our standings after three rounds of play
absolutely
the standings are still fairly
straightforward with only one decisive
game per round so far there are three
people at the top uh uh yanni bom nishi
wesley so and uh bogdan dayak uh the
local player who is having a fantastic
tournament absolutely up until uh this
point uh four players on three draws so
far and then there are uh three players
who have lost one and drew two including
two two of the candidates which is quite
surprising and remarkable indeed and our
format peter the farmer is a templar
round robin with uh 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves and then 30 minutes for
the rest of the game with an increment
of 30 seconds starting from move one no
draw offers are allowed at all and there
is one point for a win half a point for
a draw and no points for lost standard
scoring system with three rounds under
our belt what is our remaining schedule
uh we have two more rounds to go
including today until the rest day and
after the rest day there will be four
more rounds all starting at the same
time and playoffs if necessary on
saturday
thank you peter and alejandro as always
good to see you my friend pleasure to be
here with you guys bright and early in
st louis but ready to get started in
bucharest and remember this is our
inaugural event of the 2022 season of
the grand chess tour this is the part of
a series of events but let's take a look
at what happened in previous year we
started the tour in 2015 with only
classical events and it was the world
champion magnus carlson that won in
dominant fashion second place was
anishgiri and third place was lavona
ronyan it's not forgetting that year
maxima shayla graph had a very good
showing but didn't quite make it due to
some tiebreak regulations meanwhile 2016
it was all about wesley so in that year
it seemed like wesley was just winning
everything outside of the world
championship match which he didn't
qualify for and magnus of course took
that year off to play against karjaki in
second place was hikaru nakamura and
third place fabiano corona made the
american trifecta in 2016. meanwhile in
2017 we had the return of the champion
magnus carlson claimed first place in
that one maxine vasherla graf
took advantage of the fact that we added
rapid and blitz to the mix and he got a
very deserving second place that year
three points behind magnus third place
went to lavona ronan has played every
single tour so far and is still playing
it this year in
2018 we added a new twist yes you've
accumulated gct points but you were
doing so to qualify into a final event
the london chess classic served as a
semi-final and a final for the tour in
that one hikaru nakamura prevailed over
maxine vasherla graph by knocking out
fabiano carana in the semifinals fabi
beat levon in the third fourth place
matchup 2019 it was again a final in
london and this one it was won by
dingley ran dingler and had a great year
won the singfield cup qualified to
london but it was mvl actually that
knocked out magnus in the semi-finals
and then it was ding that beat the
freshman you can see that mvl has
actually done great throughout the years
in the grand chester even though he has
not claimed one for himself in 2020 of
course we had the pandemic we couldn't
have the grand chess tour as scheduled
and we returned in 2021 with some
difficulties of course it is a global
event a series of events and we just
didn't get around all of the pandemic
restrictions we still had a tour but we
had a ton of wild cards 19 to be precise
and three players that were able to
participate in the tour fully took
advantage of that wesley is of course
the reigning champion of the grand chess
tour he won in 2021 and he has a big
matchup today in romania and to take a
look at it let's go with our friends in
bucharest anastasia and christian
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to day four of the 2022 super
bad chess classic from location here in
bucharest romania i will be your host
grandmaster christian carrillo joined by
my brilliant co-host woman grand master
anastasia carlovich anastasia welcome
back great to see you tell us a bit
about the atmosphere here in bucharest
hello everyone good morning saint louis
it's actually great atmosphere here
since we have weekend many many people
came to the plane when you
it's very crowded today same as
yesterday and actually many spectators
came not only towards the games but also
um gain some autographs from the players
and take some selfies with them some
photos uh bogdan had his moment of glory
uh signing dozens of autographs
yesterday after his um crazy victory
against richard so it's been a really
great day so what do you think
definitely a lot of fun so far here in
bucharest for the spectators as well how
about the games anastasia we had a lot
of very exciting matchups but what do
you have your eyes set on for today
of course i'm looking forward towards
the game between ali reza ferruja and
richard robert even though they are not
doing so well so far
both of them literally motivated you
know to show their best today and both
of the games finished with decisive
results so far so i'm hoping we're going
to have another decisive result today
what do you think chris well that one is
definitely going to be a barn burner the
big matchup between between the two
youngsters but i do have my eyes set on
on the game between the two leaders that
is the american wesley so facing yan
nepomniyashi well this one is a great
matchup but i have to say it is wesley
so who has the upper hand in this direct
matchup five wins for wesley only one
loss and four draws but these players
right now are at very different stages
in their career at least this is the way
i see it yana pomnyashi just finished
his world championship match against
magnus carlson he has a lot of unused
preparation that he's definitely going
to unleash in this event as well as the
following candidates wesley so on the
other hand well he's been playing a lot
recently and we know he likes to use his
preparation right now unfortunately i
don't know how much of that preparation
is still available because he has been
using it in so many tournaments the last
few months nevertheless this one is
going to be a very very exciting
matchups how about you guys well thank
you christian thank you anastasia agreed
two very mouth-watering match-ups to to
be sure but peter let's take a look at
five yeah i'll
and what do you have for us uh the
pairings for today are uh
a very quiet and uh frankly lackluster
event so far is white against bogdan
jack who's been playing very well but
still you know if you if you have to
look for a mark in this tournament there
won't be any but as close as you can get
it's probably white against uh dayak so
shakira probably will be uh very much um
yeah out
yeah
the game between feroza and rapport two
candidates two players who are on minus
one so far both of them obviously
desperate to improve their situation in
the tournament exactly then the clash
between linear and levon and then
obviously that that bearing of our
tournament leader especially so uh
against uh yaniponishi and apart from
being five one up i want to slightly add
to that stat i think uh because it
didn't go like one zero one one and then
four in a row i think
up until very very recently it was a dry
score in in favor of wesley it was an
incredibly uh annoying matchup for jan
which has improved somewhat by the fact
that
he did win one eventually he did as we
see and there we see him uh arrive at
the board with uh
uh
i haven't seen each other
yeah i haven't seen him do that very
much but i uh
uh i guess he is now in some kind of a
supplement regime or something because
i'm sure they're being fed well in the
in the players lounge so i don't i don't
think you have to necessarily need to
bring in food to the
uh to the round but
right and of course i also like the very
heavyweight matchup between mbl and fabi
to round out our
pairings uh for me
mvl uh as alejandro said uh really
successful in this tour except the first
three rounds alley andrew rather quiet a
little quiet but as we were talking
among us ourselves in the berk as we
wait for the first move to be played
here oh and i just want to interrupt you
to say we have a very special
lady making the first this is anna maria
pesco who is the romanian fencing
champion that'll be at the service she
has european she has been a former
european fencing champion wow
and
i would let her play anything she wants
but i think shaq told her to play d4
that's true i mean anybody who's a
fencing champion peter is all right with
me i want them on my side
and uh quick question peter what are
they playing for uh there's plenty of
mula at stake yeah there's a six figure
first prize there and the gcd points
column might be slightly confusing but
you you get more gcc points if you win
the event outright and slightly uh fewer
if you have to play tie breaks uh 65 for
second 48 plus for third and going all
the way down to 10.5 for the last place
uh very very nice prices in the gcts per
usual yeah and a total price fund of 350
000 for this our first inaugural event
and
as we get started we
were talking about the three match ups
uh that we especially like and there was
our
matchup between the two
is that a shark on this shirt that's a
lot of sharks on his shirt
is it sharp
yeah i was about to say uh
well the ever dapper let's put it that
way lavonne aronian uh fashion plate
that he has the the knight f3
knight f3 by uh yeah
definitely does though he does
everything right he is an extremely
well-rounded player when it comes to
opening prep and uh
is the author of a
very very influential 1e4 course i i say
that without
you know any kind of any semblance of
jest i we've seen it being used at the
highest level i think magnus once
struggled potentially against wednesday
himself
uh when he actually went into a line
that was covered in depth in the wesley
course and for some reason was not aware
of what the wesley course recommended
there
uh that was a weird game because wesley
ended up losing it right
i think he made a mistake almost
straight out of the opening
no there was definitely a game that
magnus
in some c3d4 italian i want to say
i'm thinking about this like knight g5
freight liver stuff
but we are straight into a catalan
between these two yeah just recalling
yesterday's game where wesley so was
black against fabiano and we just see
the same defense
bishop e7 also chosen by jan i mean
again there are
many many ways of playing against the
catalan and i just find it interesting
that wesley happens to have the very
same position
as he did yesterday except
from the other side now yesterday wesley
has played d5 take c4 and then we saw
queen a4 and we were
and guess what d5 takes c4 well jan uh
did have you know
a reason to look at the catalan quite in
depth because that was one of the things
one of the things that magnus definitely
tried against him in uh
in their world championship match and
actually the catalan games were
i suppose the liveliest of all the
magnus tries with the white pieces
exactly um so yeah i mean clearly both
of them will uh will know what they're
what they're on about there now because
we were looking at these lines yesterday
queen c2 and b5 and the differences
between queen a4 and a6
there is a third try
that was from i guess ages ago uh
victor korchner
and anatoly karpov world championships
19e in knight e5 and knight c6 was
played i think today i think it's
supposed to be actually a solved force
draw pretty much really it still exists
but it mainly exists as a way to either
to just briefly check if if your
opponent remembers or to just strip the
line or to just straight up you know
kind of ask would you mind the draw and
and get that draw because there are some
repetitions even i remember and i played
this with no colors
why did i play this with black and even
i can name a couple of repetitions that
that occur there fairly uh fairly
frequently well
i i we get to answer the question
that i wanted for the world championship
if he just goes into the straight
mainline catalans what was nepo's prep
and
we're about to get the answer
i thought it was going to be this b5 a4
bishop b7 line we were talking about
yesterday because it was so in vogue
just by the time that the world
championship match came around
and i'm curious if that's what we're
going to see
i believe the movie for
israel i think
i think magnus played in 95.95
[Music]
he played like an earlier 95 right oh 95
here right i think it was here yeah
but
i remember i made mistakes on this topic
while i was actually casting the game
and i'm probably wrong again but i have
a feeling it was here because if you
play a4 you will no longer play 95
because black will play bishop b7 most
likely right in the current meta so to
speak
just out of curiosities
but i think he unchosen 95 and then i do
too yeah
a4 c6 and then something
uh 46 knight c3 i think f6 knight of
three and queen d7 no yeah that is
correct this is what i seem to recall
yeah
and it was quite it it was a really
really enjoyable yeah
rich
lots of content yeah white probably were
doing quite well at some point and then
jan was borderline winning uh round
about move 30 but missed a couple of
opportunities to
uh to push and then
defend it quite well and it was a draw
all right
95 c6 first oh yeah yes yes 1966 a four
night a 400 yeah that's that's the way
yeah yeah that was the move order 95 c6
a4 from the world championship match in
dubai
with knight d5 95 and now knight c3 f6
and we transpose back to what we're just
discussing
uh
so we will see b5 has been played none
of this should be a surprise obviously
to wesley because you know this is the
world championship game
against the catalan so yeah you just saw
uh wesley kind of staring off into space
there is
just recalling the files yeah and also i
want to say that uh you know considering
that you i think you have a very heavy
expectation of a4 being met with bishop
b7 and those lines are
absolutely risk-free for white but
probably are a forest draw uh and we
have been talking a little bit it seems
like we're criticizing wesley but i mean
he's been winning tours with this
strategy so i don't know how much
criticism
needs to be applied to it for me it's
not a criticism it's just the way he
handles things
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be a shock
for him to just play this ab5a6 betaxa6
perhaps ask one slightly newer question
somewhere have it probably answered
because jan has you know decent memory
and generally can solve problems over
the board as well and the game just you
know ends in a draw because both players
played well in theory here just plex
stands well according to you know the
current state of theory in this line so
that's one choice or he could go for
something much more adventurous starting
perhaps with knight t5 to disallow
bishop v7
definitely as we keep our eye on this
matchup between
our two leaders what other games have
you kept your eye on alejandro
well we have a lot of heavy theoretical
duels potentially in this tournament one
of them you can kind of expect it's
going to be between mvl and fabiano
carana of course they had a opening duel
for a little bit over a year as fabiano
corona prepared that night or famously
in the candidates against mvl in 2021
but here we have another straight into
theory deep stuff kind of variations
let's take a look how we got there
fabi's black mvl is white we have the
spanish everybody knows about this and
knight takes e4 the open spanish it's a
rare guest in fabi's repertoire he
actually uses it mostly with the white
pieces he is better known for his
archangels or anti-martials but knight
takes e4 he's employed once in a while
uh d4 b5 and we go straight down deep
into theory d takes e5 bishop e6 c3 and
this is more or less the main line of uh
this is the main line of the open
spanish knight bd2 is certainly the most
common move throughout the years the
move c3 is the second most common and
it's been seen more and more uh recently
bishop c5 knight bd2 castles bishop c2
and we go deep into this line that's
been essayed many times before there is
the possibility of keeping the center
attention with the move bishop f5 or
something like this i've seen the move
f5 played as well to maintain this
knight on e4 but another way to solve
your problems knight takes f2 this is
what we tell beginners not to do you
don't give up
two bish two minor pieces for a rook but
it comes with very specific compensation
in this kind of positions let's take a
look at what's happening knight takes
rook takes this is first bishop takes of
course king takes f2 f6 the idea is to
rip apart the position while these guys
on the queen side are sleeping and this
king is on f2 but this is all theory
knight f1 f takes e5 king g1 and queen
d7 played queen d7 must have caught
maxime off guard because the move bishop
g4 has been seen before in some
top-level games including maxim with the
white pieces against mahmoud yarov
khalsan also played it against
mamadiarov uh queen d7 i don't have any
great games with the database except for
a very recent one in 2021 grendel use
used this with the black pieces against
a very young and talented player jonas
pierre
queen d7 is not common queen d6 and
bishop g4 are the moves and i believe
that favi has stood up from the board
not expecting his opponent to reply
immediately after this long string of
theory queen d7 i don't quite see
immediately why you would prefer the d7
square over d6 but i'm sure that as the
game transpires and i analyze this a
little bit more with the engines we'll
have an idea of why the queen is on d7
and not what seems like a more
aggressive spot on d6 where you're
threatening sometimes to go e4 and
control the diagonal
while they're just in the theory uh the
first question i think i would ask and
most people watching our show will ask
the same what about knight g5
i'm guessing bishop 5 is a reasonably
comfortable reply here
and
having that f5 square covered by more
than one piece is perhaps useful here
with the queen on g7 i do want to point
out not point out but director of
viewers that game that alejandra
mentioned a bit earlier between uh mvl
and shakira
that was a very very interesting game
and it also featured
one of the more remarkable quote-unquote
blunders in in recent top level history
because uh i think shaq at some point
missed what amounts to a forced win
but the force being suggested by the
machine there is so outlandish that
perhaps at some point later in the show
if you uh
i encourage the viewers to have a look
and perhaps alejandro could track this
down for me because there's a specific
moment in that game which i think
sort of bears putting on the board and
showing to the viewers it's very very
spectacular uh but that's all uh in the
past now because bishop g4 has not
actually been played
um once again peter uh in this position
after the bishop kind of annoyed me
there yeah
knight g5 tickling the bishop tickling
the h7 pawn yeah bishop f5 looks fine i
think the mission really looks very very
threatening with knight e3 coming up
yeah that was my question let me go 97
and c6 ah 97 i i actually tried rook d80
a second ago uh how does it go 97 93 c6
i'm not very happy about giving up the
bishop on the five but i would be even
less happy about plundering the g5 that
that is a good point indeed uh here we
could just see maybe uh
i don't know
queen g6 neither five or something and
two bishops
these positions are incredibly baffling
to me because they look like they like i
i vacillate
wildly between liking black because of
the wonderful pawn center and also i
generally just very much like the
positions with a couple of bishops and
and uh minor pieces against strokes so
you know in my mind there's this
constant
battling yeah between
those two instincts yeah because
it is a wonderful wonderful pawn center
completely unchallenged for the time
being but on the other hand white simply
has more pieces on the board exactly so
if some kind of an attack against the
black king starts for instance it often
just becomes instantly decisive due to
the fact that white has more forces
and by that point it doesn't matter what
the forces are called like yes yes it's
a rook and i have a knight but if i have
more of them
very good yeah it will just become more
important for me one of the absolutely
great classical games uh
was this a game between uh
vasilis mislove and sami rushevsky i
think it was in this ussr versus
usa match and it was this this variation
and
smeslov
played
absolutely flawless game and won it with
the two pieces
and i think that kind of discouraged a
generation of americans
but i saw
a generation of russians including
arthur youssef who love to play the open
spanish what else do you have for us
alejandro a little bit of chess fashion
making their way here in one of our
marquee matchups ali reza ferruga
against richard rapport they're playing
a sicilian and it's a crazy sicilian
it's a crazy sicilian that i think we're
gonna see more and more at the top level
of chess because this fashion cuff it's
becoming incredibly popular it's making
a comeback for one reason or another but
the traditional way to get to this
fashion club allows two things a the
rosso limo the bishop b5 variations and
b these knight d5 ideas that were seen
in the 2018 world championship match
between magnus carlsen with the black
pieces and fabiano corona with white so
one way to get rid of both of these
problems is to use this move for the
fortnite sicilian move order to try to
get to the special cup the idea is that
if you go knight db5 d6 bishop f4 e5 we
get to this fashion cuff in a funny move
order because you're both down one tempo
which equalizes uh the tempe this is
exactly how we got to this fashiony cuff
when fabi played it in this tournament
but we're gonna see the other variation
here it does give white the possibility
of taking on c6 and that just starts
craziness b takes c6 is more or less
forced details d6 goes into a bad end
game e5 knight d5 and knight e4 this is
one of the ways that white can fight for
an initiative knight takes d5 has also
been played by knight e4 is definitely
the main move and the
idea for white is pretty simple you go
c4 you kick out that knight you
establish a strong pawn center huge
amounts of space however the specifics
of the position give black some some
resources queen c7 attacks this weak
pawn you have to defend it f4 is pretty
much the only move and then queen b6 and
the idea is that you're getting control
over this diagonal and it's not so easy
for white to counter challenge it
theory goes like this c4 you hit the
knight the knight doesn't have a great
spot to move on right now so you start
with the check
the king
he needs to move if you interpose on d2
either queen e3 or even knight takes f4
just picks up a pawn so ke2 is played
and now the move f5 bishop a6 was
considered for some time a long time ago
like the only move on the main line but
people realized that after bishop a6
king f3 you were just helping the white
king reach a better destination and your
bishop on a6 not exactly the best piece
instead the counter attack f5 you hit
the knight do you wanna impassant
because if you're in poisson in this
position i take back with the knight i
save my knight and challenge your knight
on e4 the more the center gets open the
more unhappy you are going to be about
that king on e2 so what happened knight
f2 was played bishop a6 the king went to
f3 anyway but at least black got in the
move f5 97 and the players blitzed out
pretty much to this position that has
been seen before uh in a couple of and
not in a couple of games and over 80
games of chess despite the fact that we
are still really deep down in theory uh
move 16 we've had tons of top level
games in this position uh mvl has played
this against dominguez karjakin against
vidiq adams against tivanchuk this goes
down all the way back to the late 90s we
even have games between alexei shirov
and michael krasenkov so a lot of top
level chess has been seen from this
position
it's just that theory hasn't really
settled on whether white really has an
advantage due to the
position here on d6 or if this is really
all just mirrors and smokes and truly
black is doing okay can hold on to the
pawn on d7 without issues and start
counter-attacking both the king on f3
with a move like g5 or in the queen side
where you're gonna have to dedicate some
resources to eventual breaks and
potential attacks like the one with the
b2 square and this is their lifetime
score it's a very young match-up firuja
is just entering the elite and that's
why he has so few games against most of
these players against richard it's just
one win one loss and zero draws
wow uh king e2 king f3 peter echoes of a
game we saw yesterday of lavonna
that didn't work out very well for a
while this one this one is slightly more
sound i will say uh and uh yeah theory
very much continues i i feel like there
has been uh a
number of recent games where basically
play doesn't actually start until maybe
10 moves from here where black wow black
is aiming for some end games where black
drops drops upon d7 i think in
particular uh in order to force white to
trade on b6 and then they uh try to
establish some kind of a clamp on the
queen side uh
so
it depends on how well uh i think rich
uh richie has to be expected to be quite
well booked up for today because it
clearly is his choice i don't think
svashnikov and or this move order of the
specialist is necessarily his repertoire
in general right so it's his choice for
today he must have he must have looked
at it uh
prior to playing it uh
i don't think alireza expected this to
happen
which means that we it's now a question
of just how well he remembers he clearly
has looked at it because he went for the
absolute main line the most principal
reply he chose
uh but still there's still plenty of
theory here to uh to discuss and
uh and uh yeah we're being informed that
uh
actually that there's almost 200 games
played starting from here wow i'm
guessing including engine games because
i think this this line is a uh
a favorite one to uh to give machines uh
to chew on um
and i'm assuming that the move queen d6
this invitation to has already been
declined yeah yeah is actually pretty
good for white once this knight gets
chased i'm not sure where i should do it
it probably doesn't make a move anymore
yeah so it has to go to g6 or g8 maybe
even
the this would be just a lights out
horror show for black which is why we
saw the move queen b6 and as
alejandro was saying you kind of tickle
b2
maybe in some positions you give up d7
by playing c5 and bishop b7 do you
personally have any experience no i've
i've been on either side i've been
staying away from this for for like i
don't play the threshold with black so
no reason for me to study from that side
and from the white side
i
tended to
kind of steer away from this as well
i've had some recent experiences uh in
the in general in the line after 96 b6
e595
but
people i think started trying out some
slightly more random move orders and i
think i lost the game to uh uh
christopher uh christopher you
uh recently america's christian for you
yeah or some so online i did something
wrong and just got mated but it
definitely wasn't this kind of a tabi it
was something else
and i mixed up some more orders and
won a piece somewhere in the center and
promptly got mated which is nice which
is what often happens in this line to be
honest i like the fact that you're a
piece ahead how about yourself alejandro
any experience uh first-hand experience
for you
in what may be a very topical uh
position these days
yes and no i actually ended up playing
the four nights for my qualifier for the
world cup last year okay with the black
pieces so i did study these variations
but
i used uh
here after 95 94. queen system is
actually not the only line there's been
a little bit of a resurgence of the move
bishop b7 at this position and the move
c5 i think we should be sounds a bit
more accurate uh it also goes into some
crazy long lines there's a bunch of
games
in that variation but it handles
completely different than the queen c7
line so kind of a yes and no and those
are actually played with white all right
there you go
there we go and uh this current position
after bishop e2 as peter you were
mentioning close to 200 games is that
the uh pardon me alejandro is that the
most popular move in this particular
position sorry did you say bishop e2
yeah i think i have to show you on the
board yes yeah that move doesn't exist
aha we have a novelty it's not a novelty
it has been played
four times but not it's a it's a novelty
in grand master chess
this is very very interesting to me uh
what does that mean graham like novel no
grandmas no grandmaster has ever played
amateurs have played bishop e2 or
2300s okay some strong 2300s i wouldn't
go as far as amateurs but
but i've never seen bishop b2 and i
don't know the move
it's a decent practical choice yeah it
isn't practical choice against uh you
know against somebody who
i've been told that gurkish played this
i don't have that in my database but
judging from my experience of the
previous american cup i'm not sure how
much i trust the van on this one
ah okay well there you go uh the
gauntlet has been
thrown down peter i mean he's very much
fired at uh i don't know how the how uh
our producers are gonna respond to this
type of a challenge
general's trying going on i understand
that alejandro is having trouble with
his microphone
somehow
somehow we're not picking up your audio
anymore what happened there bishop e2
okay explain the strengths and maybe
drawbacks of this movement well the
trouble because we've just blundered the
pollen because haven't we
i'm kidding it's not it's obviously not
a blunder and i'm not sure if queen xb2
is particularly great either but it
might just walk into a lot of trouble
right i don't know about knight d3
specifically but maybe even like the
tempo yeah and then knight c5 93 does
sound interesting yeah
my instant reaction would not be to take
on bits so even even uh if i didn't
suspect that there is of being of only
faking being unprepared exactly exactly
because it's it's not such an important
pawn and spending so many tempe on uh on
just taking it yeah it feels
feels uh kind of irrelevant uh i mean
the plan generally involves playing 65
going bishop b7 with bishop c6
uh and also a very important plan part
of the plan here for black is to perhaps
if allowed try to undermine the wine the
white structure with g7 g5
uh probably not until we've put our
bishops on our bishop on a long diagonal
but definitely definitely afterwards
the idea of playing g5 even as a pawn
sacrifice just to break apart the white
structure in the center
if it gets accepted
and then perhaps playing h6 or knight g6
or something along those lines just open
files for your pieces because black
apart from being somewhat cramped is
definitely
you know one thing that black would like
here to achieve is to get some uh open
space for uh for their pieces of the the
rooks in particular
um bishop zoo is i'm guessing an attempt
to save a tempo on b3 if you expect you
have to take on b6 anyway some sometime
later
uh perhaps b3 is unnecessary and perhaps
you can use it sort of
more productively and this is i guess
what this movie is about so
i did look it up uh what the producers
told us about gucash playing this
variation surprisingly it's true
eating is words
on live television my goodness it's a
very recent game actually it's played in
a tournament that's still going on
somewhere in
spain and guke played this against alina
saba on upcoming female player from iran
i believe she's something along the
lines of 18 years old and well above
2300 but gukish played bishop e2 and
absolutely destroyed her so clearly
something that players around the world
are looking at
wow spoken like the coach of a major
university as you know these youngsters
and
probably in line for scholarships
maybe that's the plan bishop e2 i i
understand uh farouza he's completing
development on a good day that night
will swing to c5 and you know the king
will
in any queen trades will take care of
itself so bishop e2 connecting the rooks
and uh very much uh as
uh black what are you going to do with
your king your camera
it goes to f7 and chills i don't think
black pretty much never cares about the
d7 pawn even like here it's clearly
untakeable because the queen immediately
immediately gets captured right and as i
say all these things richie goes rook d8
seemingly trying to protect it
i'm very confused by
not a surprise
the quality of your life just went down
not necessarily
like it's interesting though because uh
the only reason i could see for this
move is that
richie perhaps is actually intending to
go knight c8 and then d5 or d6 because
that makes a lot of sense the d7 the g7
pawn really does not need protecting
it is almost never hanging and if it is
hanging uh
black does very often just sacrifice it
for for tempe
so the go rook g8 here i i think the
only way to yeah but after location one
how happy are you continuing with that
plan you probably well i was thinking if
you do play knight c queen a3 right yes
precisely i was going to stay on this
diagonal uh obviously i've got a uh here
let's let's continue
let's go c5 here exactly c5 now i
kind of want to well quite frankly uh
move my king but bishop takes c4 exists
here right so i don't know how happy you
are about that exactly that was like
kind of a weirdness right
maybe i'm not happy about this yeah it's
very unclear because uh yeah i thought
i'd be very happy with it i think i
still check yeah i give a check from c6
i apologize yeah that that that
that is
one of the reasons why b3 hmm
but i want to say it bodes well for uh
for for richie that he replied so so
quickly because it clearly means that
he's looked at bishop too i mean or at
least it hints that he's looked at
bishop too which is a rare move and if
it's a game which is potentially not
let's say in tweek or the the mega
update uh
you you can actually miss live games
played at the same time as you guys
there's just so many i remember that
there was a point where if there was a
novelty played at the top level of chess
i would know it because there's not that
many tournaments you can follow all the
good ones right but now all these 2600s
they have all these strong engines and
they have all these ideas and there's
ideas everywhere and you just can't keep
up right exactly it's almost impossible
you got the magnus store you got the the
grand chest tour
sigmund is going on right sigma's going
on candidates is next month and like
there's a tournament in spain somewhere
we're at 20 always tournament always a
tournament in spain somewhere always and
there's 2600 playing against the 2400
you have to watch that game too it's
hard being a chess professional nowadays
you have to keep up with so many
different things and even magnus
apparently you know he has trouble he
didn't know wesley sells chestable
course and you can see just how much
dedication it takes the move bishop v2
extremely rare rook d8
seems to be a good reply it's not the
engine's top move but i'm not using a
top of the line engine uh but rook d8 it
seems like ritchie still either is in
prep or understands the positions
yeah and uh since we haven't touched a
few of the the other games i just want
to bring bring up the game between
shakhriar and
because this has uh just become a lot
more interesting in the last three
seconds did we just say g2 g4 yes we did
it's a move they often play in this
position right
i think it was uh a game of lavon rooney
and played here in st louis
where it was like student body right he
shifted everything towards an attack it
was against fabiano i believe it was
like an amazing
amazing game which he ended up losing
this is a thousand candidates
yeah that was a candidate
yeah
this is a very very topical line on
which i feel uh
i would i would really hope to pass the
the the
the responsibility of giving a lecture
on the introduces of move orders here to
somebody else i just know that it's
extremely topical and often leads to
very very exciting very sharp positions
but
uh
mainly it's a
well it's a kind of a topical way to
play the the ragosan slash vienna vienna
systems which has gained a lot of
popularity over the i don't know the
last five years i would say maybe
and uh uh people started off by you know
naively winning the g4 pawn
yeah or perhaps not even sacrificing it
stupidly right you know who does that
these days but these days you see
exactly what you're watching on your
screens right now uh very very often why
just plays around the fact that they're
born down here and it's a central pawn
on d4
pretends it doesn't exist in fact you
could maybe make an argument even that
it's useful for white to have it there
because it prevents black from
potentially trading some pieces
and
why just goes all out
trying to give mate on the king side
using the fact that they're much better
developed this is the first and the most
important i would guess of the the
facets of the impending attack on the
king side black has steal
all of their queen side on their
starting positions
and secondly using the the pawn on e5 is
a very nice like
a divide in the position which
prevents black from comfortably bringing
pieces over to the king side right
whereas black
pretty much at every single point will
be extremely happy
just to you know as you can see on your
screen 97 instantly chosen over knight
c6 nobody cares about the g4 pawn from
either side of the board right black
wants to bring pieces closer to their
king which is why 97 knight f8 is a very
very typical maneuver here
and
if i can i just share one one idea as to
why
uh black may not actually want to
necessarily put his knight on c6
something like this is extremely
dangerous followed by queenie 4h4h5 yeah
exactly you just get mated incredibly
quickly it's much quicker than you would
think
which is what knight d7 as you were
mentioning is all about you put your
knight on f8
and as ben larson would say you don't
get mated yeah and now you you have to
ask yourself like have has g4 been
played with the intention of following
it up with h4 or are we already all
ready to go g5 hg let's say knight takes
g5 and queen e4 is a thread bishop d3
always is a very useful follow-up i'm
somewhat worried about queen c7 here but
uh
on the other hand maybe i'm just
stumbling into some kind of bishop xc6
madness so knight takes e6 madness
exactly yeah no it's all been played
before though
the main move here is for kc1 and it has
been played in a game between gukesh
this game this name is gonna pop up a
lot guys if you guys don't know who
gukesh is and you've been watching the
grand chester forever and who's like who
on earth is that guy right the young
promising player from india we've been
having his eyes on him for many years
now he's established grand master well
over 2600 and he's making his
leaps and bounds in opening theory he
played with casey won against the
southern wesley so that game ended in a
draw wow but i'm guessing you mean after
97 not after g5 right after 97 yeah
yeah in the current position you guys in
the current position rxc1
instead of g5 because g5 doesn't quite
work you need to make some kind of tempo
move rokc one also avoids this queen c7
ideas which can be quite annoying
hitting both the pawn on e5 and the
bishop on c4 and it just asks black
what's your next move exactly because
you would want to go knight f8 but even
though it's a nice defensive move you do
give up the pressure on e5 so it makes
g5 a little bit more comfortable to
actually the other way to go would be to
play a5 but once again it does feel like
we're sort of grabbing pawns as our
hearts burns on the other side of the
board like you might get mated winning
the second column before because i think
white just doesn't react i'm pretty sure
ba doesn't happen b5 doesn't happen it
just stays on before and gets captured
yeah and then you're g5 h4 you just
sacrifice
sacrifice the queen side get on with
business on the queens on the king side
uh by the way for from shaq's point of
view uh yesterday in the interview
alejandro he said
i gotta win some games which i thought
was very perceptive yeah i mean yeah
that's how you win the tournament
well he was he is the defending champion
in this bucharest event and he needs to
win some games and uh as peter was
mentioning there aren't too many targets
and the local boy is actually
quite strong
it feels extremely offensive honestly
he's on plus one and leading the
tournament he's not the mark here
but but with two blacks
but you you have to you have to target
some games right
the the the white game against him it
does does sound like perhaps a better
option to to go all in
and the lifetime score between these two
guides
that's easy they played last year that
was it that was it
that was it not too many uh
not too many clashes between them i
would just like to go to the mvl game
for a second because uh i'm more than
curious and actually there was no knight
g5 it was bishop g5 mvl he played it
reasonably quickly mvl is extremely
capable of
you know tanking for like half an hour
in a position like this if he's
unfamiliar with the move that he's about
and played so bishop g5 played with i
would i know hang on a second it updated
just now on my screen so he did he did
spend quite some time there oh really uh
and he's still thinking after okay so
he's uh
bobby has been playing bang bang bang
bang bang i mean as you can see bobby's
got more time than when he started sorry
yeah but i mean this is an incredibly
topical line there's been a lot of
developments here recently and uh mvl
has played this game uh against mijarov
that i uh first and then myself brought
up earlier so you could expect to get
this on the board if you play the spider
the open spanish against himself fabi
to still be very much in his prep is not
a shock whatsoever but right
bishop g5 i think
probably indicates that mvl would first
of all it s
not doesn't stop 97 but perhaps slightly
discourage 97 but also i think it's just
kind of aiming for the g3 square you you
want to continue with bishop h4 bishop
g3 okay perhaps pressuring the center
slightly slightly more
and
also just developing developing this
piece without committing it to any kind
of a square where it might get in the
way of r knight on f1
um very unclear position as i as i said
every time i see the structure and this
particular material balance i
i get dizzy i have no idea who to root
for
what do i prefer here i
like the center and you like the pieces
you can't have both sides aleandro what
do you like i like the pieces
it's that simple i i hate black's
position i've tried playing it with
white
and it just seems like the pawns roll
over me every time i try right i love
the pieces but i can't handle them the
pawn slime was turned out to be too
strong i want to draw your attention to
this game between wesley and nepo
because they're going zoom through
theory and i get to make a nice shout
out so let's go first on where we left
it off we did expect this variation with
bishop b7 and knight a6 this was nepal's
choice after all in this position and
they kind of zoomed through theory this
is all well known this uh sacrifice of
the pawn for black you can see they're
down upon but they get in the move c5
they get in the move 94 white hasn't
finished development and with a little
bit of an initiative black is trying to
get enough compensation for the missing
pesh key so 94 has been played this is
all theory queenie one uh there's a
couple of games the oops i did not mean
to do that but i i can show it because
the same game there's a couple of games
between leighton j and christopher you
that we brought up earlier i get to make
a shout out about andre harding he is a
teacher for chess in schools in new york
city he's been
really influential there done great
things for the community but he's also a
great correspondence player and we know
that we learn a lot of theory from
correspondence games and they're going
through his game pretty quickly uh night
before rook takes a8 queen takes a a
this has all been played before knight
c3 knight c2 with the double attack the
queen has to go to c1
um
sorry uh
slightly different but it's the same
position it's the same position right
here queen c1 takes takes and we have
ended up getting i know that's why they
changed the move already because uh
young today took on c3 prior to playing
knight c2 which i apologize queen takes
a8
knight c3 in this position and he took
first right he'd go three first
contacts e3 yep yeah knight c2 now right
and then queen d2 and i take c3 queen
takes e3 we have this position right no
c c if c5 takes d4 see
yeah yeah takes takes on rook g8 has
been added in the meantime yeah exactly
and i guess rick diaz is the novelty so
we get this end game in which black has
the pair of bishops is down a pawn i
don't know how much you can consider
this to be suffering but it is a two
raceholder game if you put it that way
right although at this level i suspect
it's more like a
draw 95 percent of the time
five percent of the time you lose it
with no hack i think the point here is
not really it's not a it's not a five
against four sort of legitimately
because uh the biggest issue in this
yeah as yasser is uh you can't see it uh
just right yeah now now you will be able
to see it it's the spino on the bishop
on g2 that
uh is the major major point here if
white were allowed to play 911
i mean 95 is a blunder but yeah yeah but
if it wasn't
the pressure but even 91 is not really
possible because if you play i mean it's
possible but it doesn't do the job it's
supposed to because i will play bishop
f6
and with the pieces where they are if
you do trade the bishops on d5 you will
do it while also losing your extra pawn
on d4
you're just not in time but if you if
you work like if you if you play h6 here
instead of bishop takes d4 and white
goes with d1
i would suggest it's probably closer to
to lost than to a draw this particular
five against four i think is extremely
extremely bad taking the light square
bishops off the board uh solving the
problems on the pressure and just having
again
if e4 if e6 e5 doesn't somehow magically
make a draw yeah i would like this i
would love this absolutely but it just
doesn't happen because you can't really
unpin yourself very comfortably you
would like to and the queen on e3 uh
it's it's sort of in the way of us
playing into e3 and stabilizing but you
can't really play to e3 without sort of
blundering the knight on the three and
if you start searching for squares for
this queen to go to which would solve
this problem i mean queen of four does
exist i was wondering about queen f4
perhaps i mean you can't play wrong with
queen f4
nothing i think it's a very decent first
try because if you play bishop g6 bishop
six i think i can go e3
because g5 queen takes f6 does does not
work for black yeah
and i'm i'm one move away from playing
knight t1 and if i get to play knight
ivan as i've been pointing out if i get
to play 91 this is suddenly turning into
a very very large problem for black the
nepal blitz out the whole way
he's he's on 120. he has
spent some time uh but really
that game you were showing us briefly
it does feel a little bit like maybe
knight c39c2 was more precise right the
both of the engine games sorry not
engine games that would be at the
surface the correspondence games have
been played uh h6 instead of c takes d4
both of them
yeah
uh in this position yes h6 instead of cd
first
i do not know if it makes a huge
difference
if nepo's engine is stronger but
at least my weak engine says queen f4
and it's pretty far from that equal
well to my eyes uh the
trading of the pawns on
is favorable for white that is to say
yeah there's fewer targets yeah right
exactly but also i just wanted to return
it to alejandra for a second because i'm
very curious about that other move order
if we go knight c2 move whatever it is
instead of not take c3
uh
i'm a bit worried we are blundering that
takes d5 yeah but we probably aren't
right i don't think that knight on e7
will get caught right you can't really
do this i'm not sure maybe that one 9197
king h8 maybe the knight takes one
actually yeah you're kind of uh
maybe bringing this bishop to life
unless there's
does this work according to the engine
yes actually after knight takes d5 uh
you you just want to take back on d5
yeah that's that's a whole other topic
of course you can be a boring a boring
person with a pog with a pawn probably
yeah you can be a boring person and
equalize instead of losing spectacularly
but you'll still be upon now yeah yeah
it continues right quincy one is the
best move because you have to take on e3
with the queen but you don't take on e3
with black ah and the little twist is
that you play rook c8 here whoa
too fancy fps but sometimes it's if you
have an engine
it works yeah
and rook c8 is uh supposed to be
close to equality wow okay
that's uh that's interesting because uh
if y just blindly continues along the
similar path that we were showing knight
c two queen c1 instead of knight takes
d5 i think this is a much better version
because we go uh
knight takes c3
queen takes e3 and here of course we
don't take on c3 yet we take on d4 first
knight g4 knight c3 loses a piece for
white because g2 is hanging in bishop d5
knight takes d5 allows the knight to
escape so it has to take with the queen
which is and now we go bishop f6 with
a1c3 and i'm pretty sure the pawn on c3
will not survive no no
now this is a absolutely different uh
yeah and an easy easy game for black so
i think very much hinges on knight takes
d5 after knight c2 otherwise i think
knight two is just a much much cleaner
solution than what jana is doing
but the crazy part for me is that after
knight takes pawn takes queen c1 rook c8
yeah this is quite remarkable because
there's a bishop h3 here for instance
which would annoy me a great deal
if i had to calculate this from scratch
but is this the five versus four that we
would like or do we think that this is
uh nothing to uh shout about well
there's gonna be a very strong bishop on
c5 putting a lot of pressure on our
pawns i think right queen d3
queen b7 or something yeah but if yeah
if i play three and if i don't lose
anything tactically why am i why am i
not much better here exactly i got the
extra power yeah how do you define i
guess knight f2 like instead of queen b7
you just take one f2 ah and then queen
a7
yeah well i just blundered obviously
that's very what kind of question is
that
well i mean
readers want to know i mean
nice nice nice guys that is uh that's
quite a variation and uh the current
position
how what's the valuation
i would i don't want to throw it to an
engine because i don't i don't trust the
engine behind me okay when it comes to
analysis of something so deep but on dev
33 this stockfish is saying plus 0.8
which is yeah it's so long it's pretty
significant
exactly
all right we'll keep our eye
i'm going to foil you i'm sorry but
queen is by far by far the most natural
position here you want to play three you
want to solve your uh
you also might currently be threatening
95 question mark question mark
no i think you would i would be very uh
like if you would be late i'd be elated
actually h6 is not the past because it
gives us the h7
unfortunately you're absolutely right
it's not exactly a pass even though a
cringe six check creation continues yeah
if you go i mean
this is one of those variations where
again uh
that is quite nice yeah that is what
you're hoping exactly
i think the interesting part about this
game comes sort of now yeah does he
bless out the move or is he sit down and
think how quick is his next move here
uh because yeah if if he
starts thinking here and you know shakes
his head once or twice you know he's in
for
he's in for a bit of an unpleasant
defense here but if he just continue
like kind of nods plays a move gets up
that's a different story because yeah
naked first glance don't like this for
black i think i'm in for i mean for a
very very long and unpleasant day
it's a move like f6 mighty one knight e1
i mean i'm just a pulling upon up here
right like it's and solving the pressure
on the diagonal i will still have some
slightly awkward pieces like you take
you go queen d5 i have to play e3 my
knight on g2 currently has no squares
the one it wants to go to is occupied by
the queen queen also has no squares and
so on but eventually i will find squares
for my queen and then the knight will
come to f4 and then black will resign
kind of you know now that f6 is played
in particular yeah
what x6 played very quickly very quickly
one of the top engine moves the other
one being bishop d6
h6 very quickly after queen f4 yeah and
the the reason the line we have just
shown you earlier doesn't work i suppose
no i think a 95 bishop g2 is the
existence of the move king h7 even
though even there i wanted to continue
the line a little bit queen g6 check no
looking stuff queen six
check if you go to h8 i can collect a
lot of material with checks and then
take on d8 in the end
at least
and if you go to g8 i can play queen
take c6 and also sort of continue for
but maybe it's a draw maybe you just go
king h7 here because the issue for white
is once bishop takes f1 happens if it
happens you cannot recapture because of
queen h1 mate
uh so let's say if you go queen take c7
you're a full rook down you can't really
play king takes f1 in response to bishop
takes f1 that loses the game um
so maybe this holds and if 95 doesn't
work then you have to make a kind of a
slower move i still don't know why let's
say knight e1 is unplayable but
but once again knight e5 bishop takes g2
check mm-hmm king of chinese h7
check
king g8 i think yes uh check king h7
king h7
now exactly in this position and rook
somewhere yeah yeah i was just but i
will play bishop six and i'm not really
getting right once i get bishop f6n i'm
not really getting mated anymore and the
bespong is still alive i'm just
wondering where my queen would be best
plays g6 f7
or where it currently is
when i uh make a rook lift um
yeah you can play something like rook
she one i suppose bishop six f three
because the green e6 actually controls
the h3 square
um oops that that was a
control the h3
is kind of well yeah
yeah with the rook
move
moved i am threatening f2 f3 but i'm
also threatening the bishop and this is
what peter means is that
by cleverly leaving my queen on
on h on e6 i'm covering h3
wow i mean it's
i
i want to say the the level of
preparation is
just feels extreme at this time i mean
they they're
we're in some kind of an ending and uh
yeah we don't we don't know how how well
both of them have analyzed this
particular line but yeah so far move 21
i think safe-ish to assume neither of
them has started really playing yet
they're just kind of remembering we're
trying to recall what the file says as
we say sharing their homework yeah well
okay this is the position for wesley to
uh dig deep and and
actually one game we haven't touched yet
at all and we're almost an hour in so
let's take a look at the linear game
against uh levon
i think it's flying under the radar a
little bit
it is a funny game it's an interesting
game and it's a rematch right we've seen
these guys play from the american from
the american cup a double rematch if you
were right because levon did play
against linear dominguez early in the
tournament and linear actually not live
on down to the elimination bracket by
beating him with black in a petrov and
then holding with the white pieces
holding maybe a strong word linear was
actually the one pressing in that
karaoke and then they met in the
elimination match and it was levon that
actually took out linear so one-on-one
on their match-ups and now they're
playing again in bucharest here's the
head-to-head in classical chess two wins
for dominguez including that petrov we
just saw in the american cup but live on
slightly better of the match here
against dominguez
and this also feels like a really
heavyweight theoretical dispute we've
just seen this move bishop f5 even
though they've been playing it rather
slowly i've got the feeling that this is
still we're we're in the trenches of
theory
possibly and there was a very little
interesting little bit around moves 11
12 where uh levon played c3f6 uh we
could spend a half you know exactly
trying to understand why f6 was the no i
mean just in general the uh the joker
piano move orders are you know a topic
you can spend basically all the allotted
time whatever the allotted time is like
if you give us two hours we can probably
feel in two hours if you give us five
seconds i can just say this is joko
piano moves have happened you know go
move on with our lives right
uh a5 we're being told is a novelty on
of eight but uh lingerie i think by his
standards replied extremely quickly so
you get the feeling he has seen this
before yeah
and this is the sequence i wanted to
point out to you because quimby three uh
i was actually looking at this wondering
if queen b3 is supposed to be met with
a5 a4 in this position i don't know if
it's a good move but it's definitely a
move that you can try
uh and then uh i guess queen b5 wins
though like if i were okay
bishop takes c6 bishop takes c6
it doesn't get captured like it doesn't
get good
ah you have a4 you have a4 sorry yeah
yeah yeah so sorry we're just uh the
five yeah queen b5 rook a5 bishop to 86
might be a refutation of this very fancy
idea that i had there while they were
playing so i guess queen b3 was simply
going to be met by
uh simply going to be met by knight c7
because importantly you cannot like the
most
beautiful looking move here is bishop b6
but i think but i think it loses to
knight g5 in as much as or maybe it
doesn't maybe there's a four there as
well but in in that case we understand
why he played f7 f6 because he wants to
maybe play the beautiful move bishop e6
maybe he does uh
i thought this wins but the 584 might be
extremely strong here you know kind of
throw through the gauntlet right back at
uh black and light quite quickly replied
to f6 by playing d3 d4 which is a
topical reaction to black playing f6 so
once the queen side the king side is
slightly compromised he opened the
center he takes d4 and then he
also very quickly played rookie one
prior to playing cta xd4 i think once
again
trying to discourage as much as possible
the appearance of the bishop on e6
exactly
and then the bishop did appear upon me
yeah
and has appeared on bishop on f5 and now
lanier has gotten gone into his tank
and thinking how to uh respond to this
uh first impressions are what about what
about you yeah yeah is that i like white
i mean interesting because i i think
this this has to be quite comfortable
for black honestly really uh just
because i am kind of used to
petrov positions
where you know you might even for
example have a pawn on c3 in certain pet
troughs but you have your pawn on f7
yeah but it's not as much of a weakening
as as we've brought up to believe and
you know shout out to ben feingold who
would be
very unhappy with levon today
because he played f6 because he played
f6
yeah
don't do that but yeah
but the bishop if the bishop let's say
gets to f7 everything gets uh gets very
much solidified and it is sort of on the
way uh you could if knight h4 here was a
move you could make maybe you would be a
bit more optimistic but i think bishop
takes e4 followed by five might be a
large problem
potentially
although queen h5 here might be playable
surprisingly i thought this just loses a
piece but actually queen h5
knight f6 knight g6 is a very fancy way
to lose the game
shout out to
uh my steam co-host diane gustafsson
who's motto he's always showmates in one
when you have a chance exactly exactly
every checkmating pattern should be
shown on there so knight h4 uh
maybe it's a completely
maybe it's a playable move but maybe
with the knight on h4 we can drop it
back to e6 f7 or we can find a good move
in this position drop your bishop sorry
just go bishop b6 queen h5 bishop f7 i
think solves all of our uh
i have no uh you have some jumps but the
default one is now hanging right i can i
think i can reasonably happily take on
c5 here dc5 rookie 694 you have to
convince me you're not like a pawn
grabber right right right
here i understand i mean a lot of what
i'm trying to do oh yeah i mean yeah it
depends on
whether or not
exactly if this fails it's
i'll take my moves back here
but it's difficult to refute immediately
i mean i can play knight takes e6 i
don't think it loses but you can go 96
night of eight and i'm struggling to
find a
you know a very comfortable way to to
equalize bishop d5 i thought queen e8
might be strong but yeah you take on a
fade first
um and perhaps i have to play some kind
of an annoying end game here if i can
find one
well good luck yeah
so far yeah so far i've no problem i
mean like i'm not optimistic but but you
didn't have to do any of this that's for
sure uh knight h4 definitely wanted but
you would also mention that uh if you
were
getting comfortable enough if you could
somehow manage to achieve a bishop on f7
you kind of think that h4 in the
composition specifically is interesting
interesting because it stops bishop g6
yeah if you do it this way 93 bishop g6
knight h4
yes i i get my bishop f7 in i think i
stabilize reasonably comfortably here
because i you know knight c7 on even my
d7 on a good day
um
knight c7 90 e7 without uh any
compromises yeah start start trading
some of your uh
attacking pieces exactly the pollen d4
is a legitimate target for later in the
game maybe even not much later an
isolated queen pond an iq
yeah put that in your lexicon and uh
smoke it um what do you got for us
what's happening in the fur oh sorry
that's the dioc game behind you sorry
i'll update a couple of the games as we
have heavy theoretical duels today i
think it's what's shaping today's round
we have of course we already saw heavy
theoretical duel between ian and pomny
actually with the black piece against
wesley so this one against mamadiarov
ambok dandak also seems to be going
through that direction because rook ac1
was played by shock and in the game
between gurkish and wesley so we had
mentioned earlier
black played the best move in this
position which is absolute alien chess
to move queen c7
of course now that you put your rook on
c1 i put my queen on c7 so you have a
discovery right but the movement should
take c6 is not considered to be the best
move it has been played all three times
that this position has been reached but
after queen b6 just returning the queen
to where it belongs the opening of the
diagonal seems to be good enough to just
shed the pawn on e6 remember the black
is up a pawn for the moment because of
the central pawn on d4 and after
eventually moving the knight to f8
especially if the bishop retreats on
this diagonal black's
counter play on g4 is actually pretty
nice uh remember that despite the fact
that we haven't mentioned it black does
have the pair of bishops the more the
position opens up the better for him
so after queen c7 mehmed did wanted
nothing to do with this obvious
discoveries of bishop 66 they simply put
the knight back on g3 probably planning
something along the lines of bishop d3
and queen e4 targeting immediately on
the king side maybe knight h5 to target
g7 and deck after a little bit of a
thing put the queen back on v8 this is
the modern chess maneuvers queen c7
queen b8 but he understands how
important it is to uh touch base with
the pawn on e5 remember remind white
that he has a weakness there that he
cannot take on d4 willy-nilly whenever
he wants to he does want to get to the
pawn on d4 keep the pawn on d4 alive a
little bit artificially it also gets the
queen out of the way from uh some
positions in the in the queen side so
queen 7 queen b8 engine approved of
course although this is correct uh in
the game between mvl and favi we had to
move bishop g5 played after queen d7 and
of course such a move is not going to
surprise fabiano corona he instantly
threw down rookie 88 queen d2 played by
the frenchman after a long thing and
immediately of course with half a minute
think the move d4 best move by the
engine of course all of this clearly in
favi's prep not the most obvious move
because i'm not sure that you want to
play d3 i'm not sure that you actually
want to break your structure with the
movie takes d3 but it does allow this
bishop to come to d5 in variations put
some pressure on the knights and
activate white blackstone pieces after
some time knight g3 was played and
finally fabi is taking a thing he's
finally spending some time just hitting
the hour and 30 mark that he started
with while mvl down to 50 minutes to a
40 minute differential between these two
players just
exemplifying favi's constant hard work
on and off the chessboard finding new
ideas finding new resources and pretty
much every opening in existence
wow the move knight g3 does however take
away some escape squares for the bishop
there alejandro yeah but if you go after
it h6 yeah your position will start the
engine doesn't like what maxima is doing
but again i'm not fully trusting of the
engines in complicated positions uh with
such material balance but h6 is the most
logical move the question is do you
sacrifice on h6 remember you have a ton
of pieces on the king side and your
rooks they're not the best defenders
there's two key lines here you could
play bishop h4 and then g5 knight takes
g5 go at it that way you have to worry
in this variation though that d takes c3
might force some pieces off the board
before g5 traps this bishop this would
be beneficial for black because it keeps
the king a little safer to just wipe out
the queens of the board maybe not a
little safer a lot safer once the queens
are not on the board the other way to do
this just take on h6 directly and on g
takes h6 queen takes h6 try to get
something here the engine does not
believe in it thinks that after queen g7
you want to keep the queen song h4 or f5
doesn't really matter both of them you
can see have some difficulties queen h4
for example you don't want to run into
rook a4 rook f4 i would put it on h5
honestly but apparently there's some
issue tactically with the move d3 which
i have no idea why but we'll get to it
the thing is the engines hate it and
finally hasn't looked at it so at the
very least we're going to have a fight
over the board fire must know that the
end the evaluation went from zero zero
to a negative because the move knight g3
is not one of the top moves there were i
do want to say that it you know uh from
a purely human perspective i think it is
the most obvious move in the world in
the position
because d4 has been played clearly with
the intention of playing bishop d5 and
you want to control the e4 square as as
much as possible you want to be able to
meet bishop d5 with knight e4 bish
before i expect 94 if if i'm given that
that choice
so
uh
yes it's probably i mean quite likely
not the first uh not the first choice of
of the engines but i'd be surprised if
fibi actually hasn't looked at it
because
even when you're clicking around when
even when you're following the engine
advice
you still have your instincts and you
still understand that i think i think
the only reason he might not have looked
at it is because we're already kind of
far from theory and even to get to this
position you already have to humanly
click around the move queen d2 was not
one of the topics but he played d4 as
you played before instantly so this is
why if he spent like 15 minutes on d4 i
would be very much uh agreeing with you
but if if d4 played is played instantly
i think if you know this position exists
you do look at knight g3 at least for a
little bit because the question has to
be i am committing to the structure
change in the center i think it's
actually hugely beneficial for white if
there's no tactical drawbacks
uh to the move93 so you have to ask
yourself why is engine allowing this why
is engine so happy about playing d4
allowing knight g3 allowing seemingly
white uh to get a very very nice clamp
on the things in the center uh so i
think it's
possible i'm not suggesting it's
necessarily what's happening it's
possible that he's sort of trying to
check what
what could be missing from
uh
from the brief glance at least that he
he had at knight g3 i don't think you
ignore it entirely because engine
doesn't say it's playable because
it has to be the the most like in blitz
you just play knight g3 there and you
just assume that if h6 g5 happens i have
so many pieces on the king side i will
be able to somehow you know have a
crushing attack in you know inverse
quotation marks
before we jump into our break i'll just
say that a few moves have been played
in the farrugia versus ritchie game when
we left it we just left it at this point
bishop e2 rook d8 uh i was looking at
rook d1 at this moment but
farrugia had a very clear idea if you
want to play c6 c5 bishop that could
drop back to b7 i'm going to stop you
i'm going to play the move b4 and after
knight c8 uh
please trade queens queen takes c5 b
takes c5 and i've got a i've got a
stranglehold
obviously or the d6 is not an option and
very understandably richard played d5
here the 6 and d5 have to be very very
similar here but he hoped at 45. and we
played 66 yeah and we catch up with the
player it doesn't look horrible for
black i probably still pick white ever
so slightly but i it feels like this end
game should be i mean i assume the
queen's come off eventually and then uh
having solved some of our structural
problems with black
and the question for me is can i get
away with the move yeah can i take on c4
or not exactly that's the whole question
taking on c5 first or taking
many many different ways of trying to do
that yeah i've
not really settled on anything uh in
reply uh because there is
maybe a problem here yeah yeah king
takes yeah it's annoying i don't know
rudy one king somewhere king c8 maybe
i can see
what happens on queen e5 in the current
position queen e5 as well yeah
right here not rook d1 queen e5 you say
oh yeah ideas of c5 and even
yeah and on a bad day queen g7
as a kind of a backup yeah
no immediate answer to be honest looks
very very strong yeah i just assumed the
queen's come off but maybe they just
don't
so uh
how much time is richie you're hating a
lot of uh
that's like a ping you know you're just
hitting a lot of uh this is just just
more theory yeah you don't go into this
variation with such little thought
unless you know it queen of five the
move is c5
obviously obviously obviously uh wow
yeah what a stunner yeah
wow and 11 minute thing but we are going
to take a break first of all we have to
ask ourselves what's on specials
and today today is a good day to ask
that question because today we we have a
very nice deal for you up to 75 off
previous year's tournament merchandise
with the code sales 75. that's
seven five that's uh
that that beats our five percent
families and friends i think i have this
shirt this is a very very nice shirt
that is a good shirt i can attest from
experience it's a very good shirt yeah
uh and this one is a 2021 maroon
granchester t-shirt featuring landmarks
from all over uh from all the cities uh
of the tour uh and yeah shop at
cubitique
stl.com plenty of very very nice
chest-related stuff there and a very
very nice deals available
right now excellent and as we go on
break we ask the players
how what's it like playing in bucharest
romania here are their answers
[Music]
we are back in bucharest romania with
the first leg of the grand chester the
superbad chess classic what are your
thoughts on this event and how does it
feel to be playing here in bucharest
yeah it's going to be exciting i mean
i'm very glad to be here back here in
romania
i am very grateful to the sponsors for
having this uh
and it's a new start it's a new season
it's a very strong tournament with all
the top players we'll see how it goes
so yeah this is for me a new experience
i like visiting new places actually it's
you know i always feel like uh going
from tournament to tournament pretty
much playing the same players and
everything it kind of gets boring you
fall into the same pattern same routine
so i like at least that there's for me
at least a new environment and even
though the players are pretty much the
same right this can
this can make it interesting and
yeah i'm looking forward to it of course
it's very nice we're good to back
again i i played here in bucharest only
one time and i played very good
tournament
it's not easy tournament is every chess
player come win this tournament and for
this reason
uh
to play good
it will be not easy but we all will try
yeah i was always watching it
from
live from home on
previous years i think it's a very well
organized tournament
and it's a very top tournament and also
very tough
so i think it's great to be here in
romania i heard a lot of good things
about this country and i was always i've
always wanted to visit here
so
i look forward to the tournament and i
try and do my best i feel good
i'm saying that last time i was pretty
sick for for the duration of the event
so that was not a great experience
only because of that because otherwise
things are i've been organized
to very high standards so i was
definitely looking forward to
to be back here and my shape
at least i'm not feeling sick at all so
it should be very good i've been coming
to bucharest since early 90s great city
and a city that i love being in yeah and
now i have many friends here so i really
enjoy the old town and
generally the whole city and
it's love towards chess
well first time here in romania and
obviously i'm very happy to be you know
back on track and
play first classical event since uh
whatever november and december
yeah it's my first time visiting romania
it's always nice
to visit new places as a chess player
that's one of the pluses
the best players in the world come back
in romania it's
very good for romania and cheese in
romania
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and yeah the plane ready would be empty
if not for them pesky kids
look at that very very nice to see uh
young children in the audience today
being being sunday no school i would
assume and yeah people enjoying a very
very strong tournament nice to see
yeah very nice to see interest uh
interest in chess being shown there and
yeah very very cute
nice little smile yeah can't start
were you like a board boy or anything
you get all of these apocryphal stories
of players who become really strong but
they started out as
chessboard boys i did that job once or
twice in my life and also
uh
yeah but not not on any kind of uh
you know grand stage soviet championship
whatever i i did when i was
one of the very very last
soviet higher leagues was in uh
leningrad at the time in i want to say
88 okay and they got they gave me a job
in the press center
uh
i obviously had nothing to do with
president i barely knew how to operate a
computer and for me uh maybe a hundred
members although probably not i spent i
spent most of my time in the press
center playing commander keen on one of
the
on one of the uh computers that were you
used to produce press bulletins i i
enjoyed every second of it
was a good game nice commander king is
something i read on texts
nice
yeah but but uh i played some
tournaments in the trigger and chess
club uh when uh the large boards with
the with the sticks to move the pieces
were were still operational right and i
would uh i would very much enjoy trying
to beat the board boys to to the to the
stick and
make my moves myself on a large part
that was my that was my my kick
not necessarily copying the moves of the
players but trying to improve upon her
well
you don't really touch other players
but you you if i could get to make my
own moves on my own board that was that
was very very enjoyable very nice let's
uh return to our
our games and we'll pick up uh on the
game of uh farouja
versus uh richie we did see the move
queen e5 when we left and then came
richie's response c6 c5
it hasn't come it's not come yet oh i it
hasn't come yet no we were just
discussing this we're discussing c5
if he doesn't know i mean
i wanted i just don't want to even
complete that sentence he's made so many
completely outlandish decisions with
ease in this tournament that
uh that like
trying to make some kind of a you know
intrigue out of will ritchie find the
best move in this position or not really
feels like we're under selling how good
of a calculator he is i think he will
it's a bit surprising that he has not
done this instantly because it really
the speed with which he played uh rook
g8 knight c8 and nd6 would suggest
that he is still potentially in his
preparation and then queen e5 kind of
needs to be checked and c5 i think
according to alejandro is not only by
far the best but possibly even maybe the
only move that
is any good in this position well
because material is uh being threatened
c4c5 hitting the queen on b6 as well as
the knight on t6 pawn on e6 is hanging
pawn on g7 is hanging i thought that the
move c5 was our main uh move and let's
imagine that uh richie uh does play it
how does it go from here uh well the the
sort of the surface level is why isn't
beat xc5 just instantly winning exactly
in fact it doesn't equalize as far as i
understand from alejandro uh the black
black reply is kind of very easy to
figure out you go queen six check
because you've got
yeah your pieces are being attacked the
king goes somewhere i don't know if e3
or g3 is better but both really seem
uninspiring because knight f7 drives the
queen away from the e5 square if it
drops back to e3 i assume you play g7 g5
uh because you do feel like you don't
want to be quick you don't want to allow
bishop f3 h4 rook ht1 some kind of
consolidation like this so right i'm
guessing you play g5 here and start
attacking the white setup immediately
feels like the initiative is all kind of
one-way traffic yeah definitely
definitely the initiative belongs uh
belongs to black here and if you take on
g7 i think it's even worse
because after the quiet move king e7 uh
the threat of oh dear the threat of rook
dg8 or rhg8 is
potentially just decisive here exactly
as far as i could tell there's no real
way
to prevent it lending with a very very
strong effect in the words of the great
alejandro no me gusta
i don't like i don't like this i don't
like this alejandro what uh what is
white uh
what's what is white doing so let's take
a look at some of the other options
queen takes e6 check
obviously forces king of faces i'll let
you guys have a little bit more fun with
this before yeah yeah throw it to the
end but then but then bishop b7 check
becomes a very very strong threat and
it's uh it's
where is my king going after such a
check it's very awkward to even make the
next move so i don't like this either
i'm kind of
wondering if you're supposed to bite the
bullet here and take on g7 or
immediately or queen takes c5 you think
i guess queen takes c5 is the kind of
the fallback position which uh should be
the safest the problem i have with queen
g7 is black could always play queen b7
if nothing else i think you might have
to but i think it's pretty decent yes
it takes let's say king e3 and i've got
this i've got nc4c5 here and this is the
position i was trying to figure out and
uh
i suspect it ends up being a draw but i
like white is definitely not worse here
before
too much uh instead of c5
yeah keep going you have to switch to me
keep going
uh don't play c5 just go real quick be
one
rook h yeah one and d1 according to the
engine black is
not surviving it's really that bad it's
like one something whoa wow
didn't see that uh
happening but as we try to figure out
the complications let's jump to
bucharest and check in with christian
and anastasia
thank you yasser yes we uh just want to
discuss the atmosphere here in bucharest
as well as the way we see these games as
well as the way we see the players
emotions as we are walking around the
playing hall and trying to understand
where they stand at this point anastasia
take us uh through at this game uh the
emotions between mamadiarov and bogdan
daniel there um i think uh manijarov
should be in a very good mood right now
i think it's the type of the position he
really likes to play and enjoys to play
so even though maybe computer doesn't
like always the evaluation um and the
position of him um he probably should be
in a good good mood right now um what do
you think kristen well i actually have
to i i do understand that of course
mamedyarov is an attacking genius he
loves to push his pawns in front of his
opponent's king he loves to open up the
king and try to check me at the same
time i have to say this is a clash of
styles because bogdan daniel deck also
loves to defend he never shies away from
these type of complications especially
if he has a very healthy pawn structure
and we've seen that yesterday as well
against report he was viciously attacked
report was bringing everything to the
table and he just defended was actually
walking around with like 50 seconds on
the clock he doesn't feel that pressure
as much whenever he attacks and i think
he enjoys it as well so this one is
definitely a very very interesting clash
now but i want to say something actually
um of course bogan has a lot of
supporters at the plane venue but at the
same time i saw one big fan of mamijaro
who who brought the flag of azerbaijan
today and he was really rooting for him
so maybe it will help him to be in a
good spirit too absolutely i think he is
actually one of his friends as well and
let's uh jump to this game as well
fioruja vs report you were giving me
some very interesting insight tell us a
bit about that yeah i mean i was i was
of course passing by the i was in the
playing hall and i think i i i had a
feeling that ferruja is not really in a
good mood today i don't know how to
explain it but when you take photos of
the players day by day you kind of see
some small details and i thought he was
really like he was kind of mad you know
before the game and he will not in the
his best mood but probably it may help
him today to have this extra motivation
and the aggressive mood sometimes
actually helps absolutely well actually
i have to say that at this point after
this last move which was played in the
last minute or so this move c5 very
important move to try to keep the
tension in the position and actually
keep black alive if he wouldn't have uh
played the move c5 richie report then
ali reza would have been in poor
position to take this one home but right
now it's a very dangerous moment in my
opinion for ali reza because the best
move in the position seems to be queen
take c5 but you were mentioning ali reza
is not in a great move i don't see him
wanting looking forward to exchange the
queens because after queen takes e5
knight to b7 it seems like things are
getting quite peaceful i as you were
mentioning ali reza is definitely in a
fighting mode if he doesn't do that if
he doesn't take on c5 with the with a
queen
well the king is always going to be in
danger and i think he's going to have
some difficulties especially against the
player like richie report and um another
one that we wanted to look at was this
one between mvl and caruana because
caruana just essayed
how many moves
blitzed out i think it was something
along the lines of
seven no 80 moves
80 moves blitzed out by fabiano i saw
him
all that i'm thinking and far be running
around so the plane when you're spending
time in the restroom uh so actually i i
don't know i think uh inval has tough
time how would you say how would you say
uh his chances look like right now
after this last move bishop to h4 now
it's the first time that fabiano
actually thinks about his move yeah just
that don't feel some harmony with the
pieces on h4 and this knight on g3 the
bishop on h4
something is wrong here i think i mean
some g5 are coming maybe but
in this case the king will build them
well we've been having our eyes on these
three games but to be honest all five
games are extremely extremely
interesting how about you guys which
ones have drawn your attention well
thank you uh christian and anastasia
definitely the ferugia game and
i'm still
uh baffled by it as well uh this move uh
c6 e5 i don't know if richie has played
but
i wasn't drawn to strangely enough and
i'm a pawn grabber i wasn't drawn to any
of these captures i was actually drawn
to a rather quiet move king g3 setting
up for this peter please what did you
imagine
we discussed this a little bit
while while we're listening to uh
christian and anastasia and i'm not sure
what the response is is supposed to be
here my initial idea was to play knight
f7 and try to sort of drag it back to
the lines we've already seen but i think
the inclusion of king g3 and knight f7
is very much in white's favor if you
play as we take c5 yes the knight is
supposed to go to b7 not f7 it tucks up
on c5 immediately that's exactly what
which probably means knight f7 uh not
the best move in the position but what
the best move in the position is i'm
honestly somewhat struggling to say
because uh you know you would like just
to castle here and say fine you know now
i'm completely safe but bc5 now i think
actually it's really just a legitimate
piece yeah pardon me that was a mouse
slip that beats
so uh it forks and there's no queen
checks as i've moved my king
and
it's a curious option we kind of know
from both christian and alejandro
alejandro's explanations of what the
suggested first line is that king three
probably isn't it yeah but i'm still not
sure exactly why there must be a
solution but the other reason why i'm
kind of like drawn to the move king g3
is because i've got this latent threat
of bishop shack which is not going to be
you're not going to be able to meet this
uh check uh on this is one of the
reasons why i wanted to go knight f7 yet
to prepare g6 as a reply to image now
just as uh christian uh was explaining
55
immediately do you mean queen c5 takes
takes knight b7
uh and as we as we have uh this shot of
the of the board and the clock yeah uh
richie is a half an hour up
on the clock which is a very comfortable
situation
it's not the most important thing with
the the reasonably large amount of moves
already made and time travel perhaps
will not be such a huge factor but still
obviously
you have to say that richie probably won
the opening duel in terms of at least
time management
uh well then i've got to ask alejandro
alejandra what would have been
richie's reaction to king g3 because i'm
a bit baffled there's there's only one
move after the move king g3 in this
position you have to go knight f7
everything else just loses
but the thing is that after queen takes
queen takes pontex the angels were
saying king e7 is fine you could also
even throw in the move rook d2 and claim
that the king on g3 is slightly better
placed in some cases against bishop b7
but against rook e3 you would have
preferred to have the king on f3 so you
can go king e3 the engines are saying
pretty much anything black does here is
fine the knight on f7 is good and the
king on g3 can be hunted even the move
rook g8 is considered to be okay by the
end as you go g5 and try to hunt this
guy down queen takes c5 was the top
engine move uh over king g3 over queen
e6 and over queen g7 even though all of
them were playable none of them were
considered to be bad by the engine queen
c5 seems to be the only one that gave
some a hope for keeping the advantage
everything else the engines were already
throwing down zeros another engine type
of position is this one between fabi
with black and mvl now mvl thought
forever in the opening because favi was
blitzing blitzing blitzing right but
favi has come full stop
it's been a while since favi made a move
and after the move bishop h4 he is stuck
he is deciding between the move g5
immediately capturing a piece traps that
bishop on h4 but encourages mvl to just
straight up give up a piece either with
bishop takes or knight takes g5 or to
throw the intermediate d take c3 trying
to get some pieces off the board now the
engine has a clear preference it wants
to take on c3 first if you take on d7
bishop takes d7 followed by c5 you do
have to pick up the c3 pawn after the
trade of queens should give black a good
end game it doesn't say it's a decisive
advantage for for black it does think
white retains compensation but clearly
not enough and if you take with the
queen you still could throw in g5 and
stuff like that but the engine actually
prefers moving the knight to d4
simplifying into the end game not
capturing this piece on the king side
just saying they're off the mark if you
trade off the queens and start rolling
the pawns for example some end game like
this i'm just making some bad moves for
an example
there are better ways to get to this
position just to give an example of this
position in which yes you have two
pieces but they're on this side of the
board they're kind of
on each other's toes g5 is a thread the
idea of bishop c4 d3 is coming very
strong i already developed my rooks your
work's still sleeping on a1 and even
simply c5 c4 d3 right even c5 c4 d3 is
very strong in this position so white
just doesn't have the time to prevent
black's ideas the pawns start rolling
and by that point the white pieces are
going to run out of space so this is the
very big question that fabi is answering
right now do i want to play g5 do wanna
do i want to take on c3 and well we are
human so perhaps he is looking at a
third and different option in the game
between lanier dominguez and aronia not
much has happened but that's because
linear in
mu 14 took a 52
minute thing 52 52 5 2. whoa in this
position played bishop f5 the engine
wanted to go a3 pretty badly it's a hard
move to explain you do know the move
exists but there seemed to be so other
useful moves in the position after a 52
minute thing he played the move knight
g3 bishop g6 instantly played by levon
because well thank you for the 52
minutes what else can i do knight h4
bishop f5 knight gf5 this is currently
the situation we have on the board the
engine absolutely hates
how lanier has handled this position
with the white pieces even thinking that
after the retreat 95 to e7
too many pieces are coming off the board
and at the end of the day you do have an
isolani
on d4 that can be exploited so knight d5
e7 seems to be the money move here for
levon to actually turn things around
from the opening battle and start
putting pressure on white
well it's not so easy to uh get an
advantage against lanier and to get a
advantage against lanier when he's white
yeah then something uh
crazily bad has gone wrong now talking
about uh
advancing the pawns pushing baby i mean
look at what shaq is doing against uh
diaca
as christian said that uh diac actually
likes seizing the defensive he's he's in
the pawn up he's got the two bishops but
he's definitely on the back foot how
good are how bad is it i would be
terrified personally playing
against coming at you with all guns
blazing no the knight on the fate means
no mate or right yes i don't get
checkmated with the knight on f8 uh it's
it looks very threatening uh both in
terms of why it clearly has made a lot
of advances on the king's side right
there's also the queen b82k8 complex
which is you know a lot of material
stuck seemingly very very far from where
the actual action is the reaction is
yeah yeah but it's difficult to
like it it looks threatening but what
exactly are we doing uh well let's try
let's just give it a shot yeah we take
on g5 and let me take with the pawn okay
bishop d76 is also not without merit i
wouldn't i would bishop d7 c6 wow
you're really tempting me to to make a a
rook lift over to the king side here
i mean rook d4 would be a v like rookie
four rook h4 would be or g4 would be a
very strong idea but i think of the
bishop c6 your sender starts to collapse
kind of crumbling so
you do have to address the yeah but
something like knight h5 or 94 with
knight f6 check to follow is definitely
very typical
i'm sorry i made your move for you yeah
yeah no why would you take him with the
pawn put it back very back bishop takes
and ponte english
bishop f3 that's three queen e5 this is
sort of what i was playing for i think
this is game over yeah obviously
obviously you're by no means forced to
do this exactly but this is why this is
why i prefer bishop b7 to a5 because i
think bishop d76 does more
to my defensive prospects on on the king
side compared to winning an irrelevant
point on before yeah i was actually
hoping that you were going to go a5 ab4
rook a3 like spend three tempi doing
absolutely nothing
let me just simply check mating you on
the on the uh
uh king side
um jump right in on this one uh
alejandro uh
it it it looks good but how good is it
uh you know the evaluation of this yeah
but let's go through some sample lines
if you wish let's go through g5 is a
very obvious move you don't have to take
it ex specifically there are moves like
b5 bishop b7 for example to gain tempe
same ideas that you were mentioning but
let's take taking actually the engines
already hate they like the move a5 say
this is just not working on the king
side we don't play like that we just we
don't open the h file and then hope
there's nothing i like the move bishop
d7 i thought it was much more natural
and bishop d3 here is a cunning retreat
knight h5 the engines didn't think there
was too much wrong with it but after
bishop c6 they thought this is just too
much you have to pull your your punches
take on the fork here with the knight
and even though you have all this
aggressiveness on the king's side that
you've regained your pawn in the center
and that you have pretty much everybody
targeting this way the engine just says
a5
thank you for the pair of bishops
black's better
wow and it's it's one of those inhuman
ways of analyzing chess but the engines
don't believe in
in the attack and i've noticed that
pretty often that this setup is looks
very threatening but it's actually hard
to create threats once you get there uh
it's of course very scary but if jack is
familiar with the position and he's not
particularly scared of the attack
psychologically he just flat out
calculates what's going on in the
positions he has good chances to counter
attack in many of these variations now
shaq is the one that's thought for a
long time and played the move bishop d3
i believe that came with a 14 minute
thing uh not playing the movie g5
immediately waiting to see how black is
going to be developing first uh so b6 is
possible with the 80 bishop b7 you could
also play bishop d7 and c6 there are
some occasions where you don't want to
put the bishop on c6 because you could
sacrifice for it opening up the e4
square for the queen so perhaps b6 is a
little bit more stable but i think
bishop d7 also makes a lot of sense
because in many cases the bishop
actually retreats to e8 to hold on to
the f7 square if necessary thank you
alejandra and of course
anybody who would like to be a part of
the conversation you can simply tweet at
us and we have one uh peter
yeah thanks for reaching out and the
tweet today is from nate yeah uh if you
had to take a guess what do you think
will could be a topical opening online
that we will see be explored by several
of the players of the candidates i
assume
the hope for an answer here is something
else something outlandish is unlikely
but something rare
like something that's not like everyday
common you know you don't you don't
answer this with like the berlin and the
petrov are going to make an appearance
for the candidates like okay we know
that what else
i i don't think the meta
such as it is will change dramatically
for the candidates i think i think it's
very likely that people will be playing
uh
what they they already uh are playing
the things like what are the somewhat
trendier things that perhaps have become
more trendy in the like in nine years
in the year of our 2022 i
you know before this game happened i was
gonna go with four knight sicilian
with i i had a feeling that one at least
one person was going to prepare
sveshnikov would this one person would
not like the bishop b5 rosso limos and
we would see this knight seas knight
takes c6 for knight to ceiling like
rapport is playing not today against
peru that would have been my pick but he
just used it here so
i don't think he's using it in the
candidates right
that actually that's another topic that
we keep on and once again we're kind of
dodging answering the uh the nate's
question but i wanted to bring it up a
little bit because
christian for instance references it
quite a bit and i think uh we've also
made reference to it the fact that
people might be sort of pulling punches
in terms of
showing showing opening ideas one month
off
before before the candidates yeah and
i wanted to hear
your thoughts on this because i i have
kind of very sort of set in stone
opinion on this particular matter uh
which might differ from yours do you do
you think it's a thing
do you think people actually don't show
important ideas in tournaments like this
for me absolutely but again it was a
different era when i was playing in the
candidates uh
i
held on to my novelties until i could
uh play them but uh now everybody's
playing so much so frequently it's sort
of like if you get an opportunity to get
in your novelty you you play it and
that's all there is to it but in my day
yeah
you you definitely held back
yeah but that's exactly the point that
perhaps alejandro has something
dramatically different to say but if he
i think that's exactly the point that i
wanted to make and the one i i've
sort of stuck to my guns over the years
on this
these days with the with the volume of
chess being played and also the fact
that
uh you know it's not really teams of
people analyzing stuff it's teams of
people uh plus the same engines for
everybody analyzing things right that
let's say if you have an important idea
in a topical line and you say uh there
is a chance i can get it i don't know
with white against levon tomorrow in a
hugely important you know first leg of
the gct but no i will wait for perhaps
like a five percent chance i will get it
i will get it against somebody in the
case next month i think it's ridiculous
i think you first do it first off most
of your opponents are probably aware of
it because they were suggested the same
idea by the same computer right
and secondly you know somebody else will
get it in
prior to you being able to the the risk
of somebody else showing
showing the ideas that you are holding
on to is so high that
uh yes you don't do it in a random blitz
tournament somewhere
but uh in a classical tournament like
this with you know
huge money and gcc points at stake and
ride and everything and you know an
opportunity to score uh sort of
psychological points
you show you show what you've got and i
don't think
i mean maybe you don't like if there's a
new opening you've prepared and nobody
knows
that is maybe the one bit of info you
you save like you don't randomly start
playing
you you say you've been an e4 player all
your life and you just decide that in
the candidates you will play play
exclusively 1 d4 right you probably
don't show your hand in that way but in
in your own openings if you have an idea
that makes sense you show it the first
chance you get because somebody else
will otherwise jump in alejandro at
least from my experience working with
fabi the way that we saw it is that we
had let's put it like this been a
novelties and been b novelties novelties
that were not exactly in his repertoire
novelties that perhaps
there are a couple that we wanted to say
for the world championship
so we just didn't play the opening at
all
for example the queen's gambit decline
that we saw with rook d8 that was
actually found very very early in we
knew we were going to play that like
very early in the the cycle but just to
avoid getting into it five didn't play
qgd
in the entirety of his career from the
moment we found it until he faced magnus
in london so he just kind of avoided
playing his main openings in order to
get um
his ideas in at the at the world
championship match but in the other
openings yeah yeah if there was a
novelty he showed it it didn't matter uh
what opening it was if he get in a
novelty he would get it in and i think
that it was more
saving novelties by playing different
openings than he was used to prior to
the world championship match even though
the players
specifically five against magnus did
play a petrov right before
uh the world championship here in the
stingfield cup exactly remember the
confession
but also interestingly uh favi didn't
play the line that he played at the
world championship match right he played
a different line and we had novelties in
both but we knew which one we wanted for
for london
gotcha
um just by the way thank you for the
question nate and again any of you we
didn't answer it well
you you you came closest you came close
enough to closest to to actually
answering the question i think you will
see
very similar things to uh to what you
think of the things that you don't often
see in the candidates like from the from
today's round i think the open might
actually be in more than one person's uh
open spanish yeah yeah because it's been
it's been uh kind of a i think there's a
lot of studying there that needs to be
done in the absolutely most topical
lines which i think uh stops people from
adopting it as universally as it could
have been adopted because i think it
stands really rather well right now i
think it's it's a very nice way of
avoiding the mainline spanish without
playing the berlin yeah if you don't
want to be playing well one of the
things about the open spanish is players
that i associate with the open spanish
wesley so uh
[Music]
they're not in the candidates
that is that is true
you put it that way right you're right i
mean those guys have b7 b6 in the game
uh between shaq and uh bogdan uh you had
mentioned and with
a very good reason uh you could play
bishop d7 c6 the the advantage maybe of
such a move like b7 b6 is you kind of
maintain you maintain yeah you maintain
contact with the g4 pawn and also if
white wanted to go absolutely all in
bishop d7 you may be in some really
outlandish scenarios need to at least
ask yourself do i have a reply to b4 b5
uh and sort of stopping hard stopping
the bishop from reaching the long
diagonal i understand it's a stupid move
most likely right right right giving up
on a3 was with the tempo
it's a thing it is a thing it's a thing
and b6 kind of secures
black in the knowledge that the bishop
will reach the long diagonal it can be
traded off by bishop b4 of course but if
i start trading pieces in this position
black is obviously quite
quite happy about that yeah that's not
the way you want to go after you
committed yourself at g4h4 another thing
that kind of draws me to b7 b6 is often
times there's a lot of lateral defenses
along the second seventh rank in this
case where you might play a5 and
discover that your rook is actually
doing really good job on the seventh
i mean essentially at some point you've
got to get going you got to you've
played g4 you played h4 you can't just
sit there and say i'm not going to play
g4 g5 i'm not going to play h5 and you
just have to commit yourself um
alejandra i see that you've got the
wesley so
game
on your screen and what what
developments are going up
not much because we left off the game
going into this end game where nepo is
down upon he has the pair of bishops but
not much has really happened he's put
the bishop on b4 you can see wesley's
queen went from f4 to g4 and that's why
why h4 actually yeah why h4
but not much has happened in the
position but nepal has starting to think
here for a very long time especially for
a nepo thought he's this very fast
player he's been thinking here for 30
minutes and i just want to make
the case of something that
comes up pretty often when i talk to
people about the world championship
match that happens between nepo and
magnus and dubai and it's that
nepal got a lot of positions
where i didn't feel it was a nipple
position
if i felt which player at the top will
be happy being down upon and just
suffering a little bit but you know he's
going to make a draw eventually and i
can come up with a lot of names and i
think
tons of names can come up there right
but nepal would be very bottom of that
list he's not a player that sits down
with a passive position down upon silent
enough you can't really make progress
and i'll just defend it um he's always
the one that looks for complications he
loves activity he
thrives in chaos his positions go minus
four plus five and he wins and loses
like that but it felt like during the
world championship match he was gearing
towards positions that were a lot drier
gearing towards positions that were a
lot more solid more technically correct
and i felt he didn't
really swim those waters as well as some
other players might have and in this
case it's the same thing he's down a
pawn
he's living not exactly on razor's edge
but if you don't find your best moves
here you don't know exactly how to draw
this position you're just going to
suffer
no question without it he didn't get his
game yeah i i wanted to i wanted to to
add to this a little bit i don't
disagree with your assessment in general
i just i sort of disagree with the first
part of it
i'm not sure there's a long list of
people who hold this comfortably okay i
think it's i think it's a difficult
position i'm i'm not at all assured you
you just hold it
full stop because i think
bishop before was a clever idea there by
jan on move 23 which we it took us a
while to realize what the tactical issue
there was because after 91 i was saying
uh instead of queen g4
we we i thought we take only one and
then after bishop takes d5 we've been
discussing what to take on d5 with where
kind of forgetting bishop takes f2 is a
very useful inclusion here without
yeah and yeah it's still a draw but
black is a little bit better yeah if
anyone uh but after queen g4 now
basically wesley is saying apart from me
one i also have the h4 square to use to
trade the light the light bishops off
and it's fairly impossible to stop i
would say the engines basically say i
have to now give up and allow knight h4
and that five against four specifically
with the knight against the dark square
bishop
most end games will be extremely
difficult to like
he took on f
takes f3 oh my goodness yeah and this
one this one is also that's a symptom
yeah that's not a move that's a symptom
and also like we we
thanks to our producers for you know
letting all of us watch uh watch ian
squirm and sit there for a bit he really
really hates what happened here right
right uh he played this line with the
intention of making some kind of a force
draw
and he realizes by this point that the
game will be a five hour grind
where you know you'll be fortunate to
save it yeah
wesley will enjoy every single moment of
it and
even a good yawn yeah
you're absolutely not guaranteed to do
to to hold that it's such a beautiful
wesley
tournament situation plus one opposite
colored bishops apart
living the dream this is like what's his
dream right now yeah i gotta say i
really don't like this i'm forcibly
reminded of the first world championship
match between the two cases caspar from
karpov where there was an opposite color
there was a there wasn't a pawn on f7
but
basically because that was a bishop last
night yeah gary got done in with a light
squared bishop here i would just imagine
what would your odds be in terms of
white's winning chances here
i think it's half half it's like half of
the half of the games you win with white
half of the games are drawn it's live
it's extremely dangerous i i feel the
same way maybe even higher but yeah it's
i think for me it's 50
draw 49 win for white and then the the
one time
blunder
but it feels really
really good obviously
a dream position from white's point of
view is he would like to put his pawn on
h5 he'd like to put his bishop on d3
queen on e4 and yeah another idea here
even though you normally are advised to
keep as many pawns on the board as
possible if you can push d5 and provoke
black specifically to take i think the
problem with d5 is that black probably
actually plays e65
giving you a protected passer just to
close the position down and have a
blockading d6 square but if you can get
the pawn on d4 for to trade for the pawn
e6 and establish a bishop on d5
supported by the pawn on e4 the pawn f7
becomes such a target
so uh what what peter is advising is how
i'm going to make some bad moves for
just a moment
boy how am i supposed to get my bishop
to okay let's do it in a in a really
awkward way uh
uh sorry sorry sorry sorry i'll just put
the move say just go bishop
you are actually allowed to blunder
stuff while setting up the position yeah
you don't actually need to what are you
doing i'm trying to put the tweet on
that nobody cares man
sorry all right
this is what you're yeah some kind of a
position like this once again maybe the
engine just holds it
right because it never blunders anything
but in in practical terms in the uh in
in the human game of chess i think you
just hate every single moment of it and
you're i think a dog and therefore
you're advising me
very very seriously advocating for e5
bishop d6 and uh
try to hold that one yeah and i think
that nepo is very quickly trying to play
against the bishop on f3 because i've
been trying to figure out what on earth
the move queen a5 was for a while and i
think it's done against the move h4
because what white also wants to do is
clamp down on that king side right we've
mentioned the diagonal b1 h7 and as a
source of play and i think he wants to
answer h4 with g6 say i'm threatening h5
on the next move at least i get the
solid structure and if you go h5 i will
take that pawn
and i'm not so sure that this end game
is unfolding i wanted to ask a kind of
uh
yeah and uh if you're if you're just
starting uh starting uh
the watches for
some some uh yeah
and happy mother's day uh this is the
standings uh on your screen uh yanni
pomnishi is playing wesley saw today so
this is the game we've been discussing
wesley is very much in the driver's seat
there um bogdan dayak is also doing
quite well today uh playing against one
of the people
tied for the last place and plenty of
players on 50
um interesting developments on on many
boards but
to continue if we could just return to
this uh somewhat dry uh position i was
wondering what do you guys think about
queen like if i passes here goes i don't
know uh h4 rook d1 h4 rookie one doesn't
matter
yeah is queen of five ever
something you play it is yes yes
because i mean queens
coming off is excellent for black but
this is queen's coming off while also
somewhat
spoiling your structure right and
opening up the f7 pawn to
additional pressure relative to other
positions
i wouldn't be so scared here this is
what i think as well it's it's very easy
for white to avoid like you can you can
go i think i think the easiest the
easiest in the current position is to
play something like queen e4
uh
and queen d5 is something you definitely
don't do because you immediately lose
uh you immediately lose the g5 pawn and
i actually in some ways think that the
move h4 also
this isn't devices this is centralized
queen f5 because we take take place
we create a weakness unless you play g6
and i'm not really sure you want to part
with the f7 phone yeah i think yeah this
stakes takes h5 looks very very dodgy
now the f pawn kind of sticks out
doesn't it you will have to play g6 and
that creates such a majority in the
center once you go hgfg that you
probably aren't very happy about any of
this now you can't it can happen exactly
uh h4 i agree is one of those moves that
definitely does discourage
uh
queen
f5 and it's a move i actually think that
white likes to play in such positions
h4 definitely would have my
vote of approval i also like your queen
e4 frankly i mean just to be able to
meet with a fight with queen b7 exactly
just getting ready to uh
free the people you know let them uh
spread their wings and fly uh it's it's
definitely as you say a dream come true
for wesley what's happening in the game
of richie because i've kind of lost my
understanding of chess once again i
thought king g3
and there was reasons we were trying to
get the knight to f7 and then christian
absolutely convinced me that queen c5
bc5 knight b7
uh was playable for black and maybe
black is actually doing fine it's
actually surprising that we didn't
consider bishop take c4
i'm sorry which moment right now right
now yeah yeah
that's also looks like a very good move
it was a good move the engine says the
bishop takes c4 was just as good as
queen takes c5 in a human perspective i
like this better because i'm not down
upon um and richie went for box box c
yeah right because curtain c yes but uh
queen c5 rook c8 now you don't have a
choice here's why you have to trade and
we happily do so and you will lose c4
but i think this is pretty clear but i'm
not so sure that it's as clear if i
fully equalized uh
rook hc1 seems to be the top engine move
but in general the point is here you do
have to take on i'm threatening um
i think i'm throwing b5 right right yeah
so you have to take on c4 here with the
bishop uh you could take once you want
to take with the knight because if you
take with the rook rook takes knight
takes rook c1 it just really
this real concern would really overpower
that rook on d8 and there's a couple of
moves to be made black's position
collapse that you have to take with the
knight
and after the move a4 it still thinks
that the engine that is the white is a
bit better you do have the better
structure your knight is coming to d3
that you have to play the move e5 start
simplifying but you'll have some issues
with the pass pawn on the a file
eventually that it is within drawing
margins but that the quality is not
exactly there so it's not as clean as
the moves bishop takes c4 or immediately
queen takes c5 v takes c5 knight b7 was
according to the engine okay
yeah i mean uh i like bishop c4 i mean
that looks like a very natural move to
to my eyes by the way after some uh time
fabi did play
the computer desired move d4 takes c3
queen takes c3 on the board and we've
been i think alejandra was advocating
for 94 here exactly yeah 94 was a move i
was considering but also the move but
the move of the engine sorry is b4
but that one i think is it's hard e5 b4
yes
yeah that's not that's the first move
that uh that's
[Music]
very strange that is not easy to uh to
even consider honestly because
everything in you screams that i mean
why are we somewhat ruining our
structure while giving white such a wide
choice of seemingly decent squares for
well first of all you're pushing the
queen to a greater square right it would
it would appear that queen c5 is a
better place
exactly and why would you play b5 b4
yeah it's completely tactical the
problem after knight d4
if we could put that on the board you
don't have to keep up with me knight d4
is fine
yes and then knight takes e5 is actually
playable
and if you throw in the moves b4 and
queen c5 on the board then 26 will win
materials when these extra queen d5 both
uh
win the game it's just like your
position just collapses you can see 594
here and yeah you cannot take on e5
because queen to any of those two
squares just too many things will be
hanging after the queen trade right
that's very clever actually yeah yeah
it's hard to come up with the move
because it's so counterintuitive before
it's just such a bad move positionally
but i guess once you spot the knight d4
knight e5 is an issue
you could stumble upon it
and how about uh moving the queen to e3
in that case and then i play knight d4
anyway and the problem is that for some
reason oh well knight takes e5 knight
takes e2 just doesn't work right yeah
yeah that would be that would be very
good for black so basically we're just
in sort of improving 94 we're improving
knight d4 you really want to get in the
movie 94. i think that's clear from
pretty much every angle it just doesn't
do the trick fully tactically it is
playable uh the line simply continues
knight d4 knight takes e5 queen d6
knight g6 and it's extremely complex but
not an idiot
no we previously in the current position
if you go 94 here yes instead of before
yeah i'm sorry
uh so so 9495 we don't have like game
very much continues after queen d5
knight g6 i guess we take on c2 maybe or
yeah it's queen d6 according to the
engine so that you don't drop c7 later
but yeah that's kind of the same point
in knight g6 here
black black still has a ton of moves
yeah knight c2 is a move queen g3 is a
move uh queen g3 is such a beautiful
shot here yeah yeah but it just doesn't
do anything yeah just straight pieces
maybe something that white would mind
actually because the result is it still
is a very attractive move aesthetically
right yes i don't understand why it
doesn't lose the queen takes d4 though
like why why aren't we winning after
queen 64. what am i missing i don't know
okay
looks kind of good it looks good for
white but yeah throwing him before is
just tactically important in some of
these variations let's see if he finds
that he's been thinking for a long time
but knight before the engines do think
that black is better anyway
okay
94 black is better
and interestingly uh
we started off by mvl thinking and
thinking and thinking and fabi
basically only went below only when
below the starting time on move 19. it
is now move 20
and bobby has 40 minutes left
remarkable
usage of the time and i think from
fabi's point of view for the last two
three moves he has to always consider
should i be playing g5 should i be
traveling
clearly not right now because rook d1 is
a huge big threat
something needs to be done about the
threat of rogue d1 i think
in this current position uh you do know
that any move that doesn't stop rook d1
from happening is probably wrong
because of just you know how how
forcefully it lands
wow i'm sorry i'm just
maybe it's uh saint louis time just a
second rook d juan
i want to put my knight on d4
uh yes sir what is this yeah who is this
yasser yeah
my feelings yeah
but what is the body count after all of
those two right now i'm up a piece
that's why okay i'm thank you
i'm taking these questions
yeah queen g6 check and i uh somewhere
around here you will start realizing the
problems enjoying the position gotcha
enjoying it and enjoying it enjoying the
position so that is why b5 b4 is the uh
computer stream the computer move but
the idea is knight d4 basically right
it's just making 94 better yeah
uh
and clearly take c3 has been played with
the intention of playing 94 in some type
of shape or form because otherwise
you've ruined your very nice pawn chain
in the center right improved white
situation quite a bit he's just trying
to figure out which is the cleanest way
to to do it but yeah he has spent
basically basically an hour on
uh a move and a thought
which has not materialized in a move
when you talk about players who've taken
lots of time let's just check in on the
game between lanier and lavonne aronian
because it seemed to us that lanier had
been playing very very quickly for quite
some time went into a 52-minute think
and what has happened since
that 52-minute thing yeah i just wanted
to show one one particular it's a stupid
line but it's a very beautiful
refutation so after knight gf5 uh
alejandra was correctly advocating for
knight g7 here
but there's a line there that i wanted
to show yeah uh let's say knight d7
knight d5 yeah yeah like exactly like
this and i don't know which order is
correct let's go with knight e7 here
yeah i understand bishop take c4 is
probably strong but i want to show a
specific position knight takes e7 yeah
bishop f7
rook f7 queen h5
and many good moves here for black but
if you play queen d5
which looks good defending you get
slightly disappointed in life by uh
oh
no which i thought was quite cute and
worth worth showing yeah it's a puzzle
rush yeah you make it into a book
yeah yeah yeah knight g6 is is but i
mean king g8 here is just simple and
strong and white is probably quite doing
very very poorly g6 maybe is playable
none of this now this is relevant i just
wanted to you know knight g6 is a nice
show that particular diagram yeah but
instead of
knight d5 e7 uh
devon took another approach he said
rookie eight
there was a trade quick g4 queen f8 i'm
a bit confused by all of this because i
thought the idea may have been to play
g6 here but but i guess bishop h6 is a
good reply yeah it's a little scary you
know yeah
and creating some weaknesses over there
yeah queen of eight queen effect is a
very stable move i understand why it's
being played it's not committing to any
weaknesses rook d8 following up that
with
you know further bringing pieces into
the game putting pressure on the d4 pawn
and
yeah probably black is still a little
bit better right um i would even think
maybe a lot uh well why did any trade
you know some improvements to uh his
position there's a queen g4
e1 has developed that is true but yeah
is hanging simply
exactly yeah
and and uh you know true to style this
is move 20 and lanier left himself 10
minutes for the remaining 20 moves
it wouldn't be a tournament without
lanier playing on increment the second
half of the game i mean that's why he is
the 2013 world blitz champion because he
started with five minutes per game
i played in that tournament yeah it was
remarkable how how he just like
the he would just habitually leave
himself like 15 seconds and then just
make no mistakes and and just be faster
than everybody else and then they're
playing on the two second increment i
think that was actually a five zero turn
even a five zero i think this may have
been a five zero tournament i'm not wow
wow and that tournament featured some
strong players and uh yeah world
championships tend to do that yeah yeah
exactly he did well there uh the
in um for rouge's game with richie they
did go right down that path that you had
alejandro and uh e6 e5 is a potential
move for richie at this moment it's uh
it's white to move the engine was
advocating for the move a4 so
sorry yes you're right a2 a4 and then e5
which
is a little loose but this is the best
move according to the engine let's look
at another game as i have the game
between shock going for the throat
against bogdan deck but bogdan as
christian say his countryman christian
kirilla said
he is a defensive player he loves
seizing the defensive he's not afraid of
these attacks let's take a look at what
happened because we left the move the
game after the move b6 g5 of course the
typical shock way of playing just throw
the pawns forward but no need to take on
g5 right now we did have to take it in
the previous iteration of these
positions but with the bishop coming to
b7 there's a direct threat on the pawn
on e5 and it feels like after a few
moves all of black's position has
harmonized because now you have this
threat on f3 you're attacking e5 and
you're finally asking white to show his
hand if you play the move rookie one
it's a little bit slow and i've
harmonized my position but if you take
on h6 i'm not taking back on h6 of
course i'm just going to take on f3
which happened in the game takes queen
takes f5 and h takes g7 this is the
current position the body count exactly
even opposite color bishops three
against uh three on the king side
technically but of course at some point
the pawn on g7 will drop the question is
do you want to take it immediately you
could but after queen takes g7 or king
takes g7 there's always king h1 rook
coming to g1 and start harassing this
king on g8 the engines actually think
black is better in this position but
they think black is even better more
better
after the move knight d7 simply moving
the knight out from the square on f8
doesn't want to go to this course
because it could get taken just put the
knight on d7 it'll go to f6 one day if
the king goes to h1 well rook g1 is not
going to set up anything because i'm
going to be using this pawn as a shield
for some time and it challenges white to
find a good move you don't really want
to trade queens in the position even
though it's top engine move to play
queen e4 i don't think that shock will
ever go into some sort of end game in
this position
so it does think that black is going to
eventually be better after getting the
knight to f6 comfortably taking the pawn
on g7 and saying look i'm up a pawn you
haven't really shown any direct attack
towards my king quite yet and the
engine's just loving the way that the
romanian player is handling this defense
very nice i like that bishop takes f3 uh
variation 97 is a difficult move to make
though and yeah we bring you news that
fiber has done something
rotated f3
uh
surprisingly enough i mean i'm sure g5
had been weighing on his mind
purposefully for the last
three four moves and rook f3 knight d4
g5 and it is a peace sacrifice right
because yes it's an exchange sacrifice
technically but remember this was a
position in which white had two pieces
exactly for a rook exactly
so at the end of the day but yeah i like
the way you handled it peter you put
your queen on h5 right when i tried it
was a different line that was a slightly
different with rook d1 and knight d4
yeah that was good yeah
how does this work no queen of three
loses to knight d4 and knight c2 queen
d4 check queen takes h4 yeah this much
this much we know this so gf is pretty
much forced yeah gf is forced
and he's done it yeah but i don't
understand how this is where's what
serverless where's the where's the
follow-up gf3 what's a plan
i'm struggling to to name one it has to
be
related to g5 but anytime you play g5 it
just doesn't matter what position you
play g5 in i go knight e4
i remind you that knight f6 is a bit of
a tickle
and that will give me a full tempo to
move my swift too even you know bishop
anyway and you're
you're you're out of uh dodge i'm out of
dodge yeah
i played g5 to trap the bishop in a
night move
so that
i have to go knight d4 all right knight
d4 threatens
g5 threatens knight takes c2 and queen
d4 check
threatens uh knight c2 yes very
important very important
uh but maybe bishop d5 rook f8 good day
f3 how weak is f3 or no all right
what what do we play here
it feels wrong
just
wrong yeah the producers you know
knowing fully well that i have an engine
behind me and i'm purposely not looking
at it decided to whisper in my ear that
bishop do you want to say good move in
this position thank you
it's actually the only move once again i
have good eyesight it's the the only
that is any good yeah actually bishop d1
is the only which is quite remarkable
but it also explains why we went for
this because it actually makes sense
right because if you go to e4 g5 traps
the bishop and you don't have the same
trick yeah you need to you need to be
prepared to meet g5 with knight e4
knight e4 and for that we need to take
e2 under control yeah you need to get e2
under control so the bishop needs to go
to d1 so that there's no knight e2 check
for king the queen and the king so that
actually makes a lot of sense bishop d1
defense against knight takes e2 against
knight takes f3 and against knight e2
and g594 still looks lost to me
yeah so we we play you know in a more
quiet fashion you play bishop d5 for
rook f8 or something and you play for
positional compensation you play down a
piece for the comp yeah this is going to
be fun
let me see how fun it is we do have two
but oh god it's not fun at all
it's a lot bigger plus than i thought
1.6 wow
yeah i mean it's it's a huge swing uh in
in evaluation he was doing really well
and now against best play he appears not
to be doing well at all but
it's an interesting idea i mean sort of
kudos for
imagining this
or possibly you know less of less of
kudos for blundering bishop d1 which
might be a you know second part of the
explanation here for why he went for
this well there was one other reason i i
mean
if i can
try to get into fabi's mindset when you
see the move bishop d1 you go yeah yeah
yeah you're kind of trapping in your own
pieces and if i play the move bishop d5
i also have ideas of queen h3 and i can
easily see how
black could be seduced into thinking
wow bishop d5 rook f8 queen h3 uh i've
got my opponent on the run uh bad things
i agree with you
it just sounds so surprising how little
white black has after 94 bishop g3
94 and just
playing the defense of bishop g3 yeah
and then what
yeah optically before you start sort of
looking into it more difficult
particularly the position after bishop
d5 doesn't really look like a plus two
position we are only at all we have two
two pawns for the piece we have very
active pieces white species
was saying white species look look
discoordinated disjointed and not really
working together at all but yeah 94
bishop g3 just solves so many of these
problems by
the bishop by solidifying the structure
neutralizing the bishop on d5 to a large
degree and that the bishop on g3 is such
as the
marvelous definitely
defensive piece oh my gosh
this is a second hold on so i go queen
h3 bishop g3 i know it looks a little
stupid but bear with me i do have a
thread of meat oh
i'm guessing queenie wong queenie juan
is just
i mean it's funny that the bishop can't
move to defend nate and you have to
defend your nate with your queen but
that's perfectly adequate right yeah it
might not even be the only move right is
it okay you have knight d2 you don't
have nine two it is a tempo oh boy yeah
we have ninety two that's uh might be
stronger yeah actually much stronger if
you could just play
you you defend the f1 square and
yeah
whoo
but uh as we prepare for a break we just
want to say on the other side a certain
guest of honor gary kasparov is going to
be joining the broadcast in bucharest
and this is the only sport where the
players watch the screens instead of the
live action very often if you're
wondering what everybody's looking at on
the left side they have the 2d screens
with the positions and of course it's
difficult to see when you're on the
chair although in the back side what's
actually happening on the 3d board and
this is the shot together right it is a
good shot it's a funny shot because
you're wondering what is everybody
looking looking at the players
yeah all right we'll take a break and
we're going to see you on the other side
with gary kasparov see you then
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry him so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us and you guys
know i can't play this right
st lou is always exploring
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in st louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from lao meyer sculpture park and the
city garden to the stunning cathedral
basilica one of the largest mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing st louis is on
display all year long
now that's an exhibit
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round four of
the super bad chess classic the first
stop of the grand chess tour 2022 and
very very exciting round so far exactly
as we are in round four what's our
current standings coming into today's
round so this is what we're watching uh
these are these are also the standings
it's it's really good yeah uh so we have
a very sharp game between shakira
yamaminjarov who is on minus one versus
one of the leaders uh the local player
uh bogdan dayak uh on uh two out of
three
uh
the game between two of the people uh
died for last but two of the people who
are playing in the candidates and two of
the hottest players on the circuit right
now are there as a ferocious with white
against richard drappard
linear is playing against levon
the clash of the leaders feature is uh
wesley seoul uh torturing yanipong
machine in a pawn up ending and there's
also a very very sharp and a very swingy
game in progress between maximo
shilograph and fabiano corona
important games
all up and down the line and i was going
to say in that game of
our two leaders we saw a decision by
wesley which is rather unexpected i must
say one of the last
trades that i would want to execute as
white would have been the trade of rooks
i would want to keep the rooks on the
board but he did it for a very clear
reason
um yeah and he gets to play d5 in a
position where he's 65 or he takes d5
really but 65 in particular is just
completely unplayable because of queen
check winning winning the game uh on the
spot handily yeah but i think the issue
here for white is that black can play
something like queen b6 or queen a1
queen e5 which i think i like maybe
slightly better even queen a1 queen e5
yeah just kind of make sure you don't
you can't blunder your bishop right yeah
just just get the get the queen to the
center and uh
g6 queen takes c6 queen takes e6 after
86 is a gorgeous gorgeous position for
white black structure completely ruined
also immediately a draw
enjoy
your moral victory of uh
of how good it looks and yeah it is good
the moral superiority here is
very strong in this one but
the only one yeah it is also it is also
an immediate draw exactly even if you
were to get everything you want pawns on
f5 and
e5 it's just three versus two yeah it
bishops them up it remains remains four
against three exactly on one side uh
queen a one quick king g2 played queen
e5 played
wesley of course is by no means obliged
to take on e6 here you can play
something like queen c4
and actually if you take on d5 you might
be in trouble but uh yeah i think can
very easily just continue
uh preserving uh that kind of a balance
of i don't know bishop d6 so maybe g7 g6
so why are you in trouble at the end
like queen c7
maybe i'm not in as much trouble as i
thought yeah i thought i was actually
kind of losing the f7 pawn
it's still
it's this is not enjoyable uh yeah i
mean i i
i'm not sure i would want no no it's not
it's not a dream but it's not a dream
it's not a dream but i think queen c4
but then quincy 4 is awkward because g6
you can go quincy a check and then d
take c6 and force f take c and that one
might not be a troll that's not that's
not a drama yeah with the queens on it
it actually might just be straight up
lost because your your structure is just
way way too broken up
uh for you to hold you might just lose
by force your bishop g4 might actually
win the material and you can just have
it
yeah but
as does f3
as well but yeah just thinking that this
structure is yeah this is this should
not be allowed yeah so i guess we go
bishop d6 probably and there's wesley
wesley really looks like he's enjoying
himself i don't think i've ever seen him
so expressively smiling at the board
something must be going on in his mind
maybe he's recalling a really funny joke
uh that he can sometimes it loops in
your mind you can't get whatever it is
out i think i think he's just
kind of happy with how today is going he
knows that you know the game will last
as exactly as long as he wants it to
last because he can
basically you can't offer a job but you
can make sure the game ends in the draw
at any point
but let's uh jump over to bucharest and
visit with christian and anastasia
thank you yasser yes
we were cracking uh at wesley's smile as
well quite intriguing yeah why is he
laughing well he's probably going to be
here in the studio later on today to
answer all of those questions but
anastasia was analyzing a bit uh the
games and she has some interesting
insights on anastasia take us through
your ideas yeah actually that's that's
cool to start laughing during the game
have you ever done this question
yes probably because i blundered
something and uh as aronian was not very
happy yesterday by blundering i'm
usually not very happy but also
sometimes i start laughing just
understanding how a battle would just
blur i am sometimes yeah that happens so
i think uh
there are some
action the action is happening now in
the game uh between um dominguez and
levon ariana i think with move g6 knight
h6 he is provoking his opponent uh to go
into the sharp position um hoping that
he can take an advantage of of time and
that he has this 46 minutes 48 minutes
against the floor only and actually we
didn't mention that yet but uh lemon has
a very nice short today full of sharks
so maybe he started to smell some blood
i don't know in this position and trying
to do something out of it it was
actually one interesting moment after
rookie one um 97 have been played but i
was actually looking at this funny move
93 with some crazy ideas after 93 rook
d4 but unfortunately it looks really
nice but white has this nice queen to
move and this rook is a little bit out
of play after that so levon decided to
play something more safe and played
knight e7 here well one thing about uh
lanier that i can tell you because i've
been watching his games for so long
right now we looked at his games live
during the american cup as well which
was a couple of weeks ago now pretty
much every single game his ending in
time trouble situation but he's very
comfortable and he actually makes the
best moves for the most part
very rarely do you see lanier blunder
even when he's pressed such as in this
game on time and i was actually having
dinner with him last night and we were
discussing his game against nepal
yesterday when they blitzed out their
first 18 moves and he was telling me
finally uh after i blissed out those 18
moves i knew that prob i hoped that
probably i would have a game in which i
will not be in time trouble he ended up
in time travel situation in that one as
well so this is regular stuff for him
now let's talk a little bit about this
game between mamedyarov and bogdan
because we had a slight disagreement
about this one you are saying that uh
mamedyarov well these are his type of
positions and he feels very comfortable
and i was saying that yes that is true
but also bogdan dak
really loves to defend this type of
positions tense positions in which he
maintains a chance to actually win with
the black pieces yeah i think the it
develops and pogba didn't fight the best
move i think you were discussing guys in
the studio that he had to play 97 here
uh so he went for a queen g7 and now
after um queen f6 proposed to to change
the queens of course
shakur doesn't want the exchange he does
still
he still tries to play actively he
played queen g4 but you know the time i
mean still i mean is running and he
doesn't have that much time for this
kind of sharp position i don't know
what's going on now but it feels like
bogdan actually has enough pieces to
defend his king it looks like even
though maybe still uh the initiative is
quite strong yes majestics follow
there is something about uh bogdan's
confidence in this game after
yesterday's big victory against rich
rapport because we usually don't see
this time differential between bogdan
and his opponents usually it's bogdan
who gets in time trouble situations and
also we know mariaro is usually a quite
fast player he almost never gets
intentional trouble situation right now
a 20-minute
differential between these two players
quite an intriguing game and i have to
say i do like black's chances in this
one bogdan's chances now
how about this game
anastasia the one between mvl and
fabiano what happened in this one yeah
of course i was following commentary so
from saint louis and
bishop d one the best move which maxim
found yeah i mean it's this was a big
move yes yes bishop d1 was a really nice
defensive move and uh after that
i'm i wonder what maxim thinks but
normally he is a good defender like all
the all the stock players and probably
he understands that it's his chance now
so and it's so important this uh bishop
is such a tremendous defensive piece
because for example if you go bishop to
d5 now i have this extra move which i
think fabiano missed this move knight to
e for this whole idea of basically this
bishop on d1 defends against knight to
e2 which would be uh detrimental to
whites not that we want a decisive to
wise position but also after take take
now queen to g4 would be a problem in
certain variations of course bishop hd4
comes on the board instantaneously
bishop to d1 a beautiful placement for
that bishop found for uh fabian by um
mvl and right now it seems like fabiano
is actually in deep danger yeah but
still it looks a little bit scary if
you're just a human being you you don't
have a gym i mean still the position
doesn't look so safe no probably um
maxine knows better absolutely not but a
piece is a piece so this one is
definitely going to be quite intriguing
uh guys what do you have
well first of all thank you for your
insights absolutely you're touching all
the right levers as far as we're
concerned uh the move bishop c4
as as
christians as you were saying bishop d5
led nowhere at least with the move
bishop c4 fabio fabi is intimating that
there's the potential for bishop e2 and
knight takes f3 check a kind of sequence
for example bishop g3 whether or not you
play queen h3 is a prelude
i think he played bishop to a straight
away straight away peter yeah i i don't
like provoking white to make nigeria
then i did two move which i think is a
very very good connecting move that
stabilizes quite well exactly this is a
move i had missed actually
in the previous iteration
it was going for the checkmate on f1
suddenly knight d2 not only defends the
mate it actually hits the bishop which
is why you say bishop
e2 and how
i'm not sure about this we can still
it doesn't really look like this is
going to lead to
such a great advantage for black but it
feels to me that maybe we've misplayed a
bit with white i think maybe instead of
bishop g3
even though i very much understand why
it should be there eventually maybe we
start with king g2
just so that we sidestep some of the
forks on the e2 square giving us a
chance to if hp2 i can maybe just take
now which was not an option at all
earlier and i do want to give myself an
option of just snapping it off if it
appears there um
it's still not very clear i think this
one is good for me i will give a check
from b3 i will play bishop g3 i think
i've more or less completely stabilized
by that point
the extra pawns are terrible now yeah
even even if the three falls yeah even
let's say after after 94 if no tactics
work for me and i have to give up one of
three i think i'm still better but i
think roon given for instance is very
strong here and i might agree and i
might not end up losing the pawn on f3
at all potentially but
uh yeah king two is king ju2 is
interesting but there is a lot of a lot
of positions which have completely blown
up uh including the
so far i think maybe the driest game uh
in the house which was the game between
lanier and uh and levon
which i apparently completely
mis-evaluated i clicked around a little
bit uh in the break because i thought
black were kind of safely better but
let's take a look at the view of his
clock that's what i want to see because
it's 30 seconds wow okay maybe we should
be maybe watching it
actually it's 14 13 12 11. 11
he's got 14 15 moves to make and eight
seconds oh pardon me six seconds to uh
on before he four time forfeits lanier
finally made a move it actually in this
particular game it will make a very
large difference between because uh i
thought one was safely better throughout
but actually the way he treated it if
lanier had like half an hour uh he was
the one pushing
even as
as relatively
recently as like two moves ago instead
of queen e6 queen of three the machine
was saying uh it is why there is there
is pressing for an advantage there even
though the game the moves that you're
supposed to make to get that advantage
and not at all obvious uh queen of three
knight takes d5
defense
yeah rgd1 apparently is extremely strong
i suspect this is what linear did not
see 95 from d1 is extremely strong here
uh
yeah
uh and uh but now in here basically uh
he saw six seconds and he panicked with
bishop takes before trading off his best
piece well first of all he started he
didn't go with the queen f3 he went with
queen e6 and yeah after 97 maybe there
is still some tactics available to white
but uh
he he no longer saw a way to continue in
a kind of an attacking fashion and
bishop takes before is obviously a huge
concession
uh and yeah black black is better now
it's quite clear the bishop on b6 is a
monster the ball on d5 is weak some move
like queen f7 uh seems logical there
might be something else as well like i'm
not even sure h7 h5 is completely
unplayable but
uh i like queen f7 jesus christ seven is
a very nice
yeah
yeah i think i think lev is now
a favorite to win this game in
particular because of the clock
situation as well as uh just that he's
consolidated everything
uh a big swing
here
don't don't you feel on alejandro
a swing in black's favor but not as huge
as white was better to black is better
it was it was around equal even with the
move queen f3 black had enough resources
he has to defend g7
kg7 is the move if we go back instead of
queen f3 there was actually a very
tempting move that after knight h6 queen
f8 if we can put it on the board sure d5
knight b4
and actually a cool move here would have
been d6
and it's it starts getting pieces on the
e6 square just to start hitting
f6 and it didn't become trivial to
defend against this possibility so
perhaps lanier was analyzing so many
different variations it's so little
amount of time and he just wasn't able
to keep up i'm sorry just
takes d6 rookie rookie 695 you take on
d6 and you play i think i saw bishop d2
in that position and weirdly white is
actually better here because of how
discoordinated the black position is
queen e6 is a threat queen g7 is a
threat
something like
i don't know maybe even queen of three
hitting the b7 pawn in the future
black probably holds but white white is
definitely the side playing
pushing yeah yeah but the current
position queen f7 is a great move it's a
very logical move it defends pretty much
everything and more importantly tries to
trade queens now when you trade queens
the sun game is really busted for white
right the quantum b4 actually super
helps black because you have r8 ideas
yeah my question is how do we reply to
knight d3 is there anything better than
bishop takes e3 which i mean it is i
don't want to play bishop yeah it is a
healthy extra pawn but i think winning
that end game will not be trivial i
wanted to go actually my first thought
was i will take one of six and play king
of fade
and
i think it's an instructive position in
because it looks like white has a passer
on e6 but you have to give it up
immediately if you don't play seven
check here i think you are busted but
you do have the chance to play seven
check knight d5 check and knight takes
b6 which may or may not be a draw but i
think it's probably closer to a draw
than it is or anything else
uh
so yeah
after 93 yeah it says minus two
apparently yeah the engine is just more
patient take on e6 take on e6 and then
play bishop c5 yeah don't allow this
pawn to get to e7 you'll win it one day
you don't have to win it anytime soon
rook d2 is coming c6 is coming right
it's coming you also want to transfer
the king to e7 and this bishop on c5 is
a solid goal
yeah yeah i don't even think that white
has any play to be honest yeah i just
wanted to bring up this idea of giving
white a passer on the sixth yeah and it
does nothing and it's it's absolutely
the best way to progress here it's much
much stronger than playing a heavy piece
end game with a healthy pawn up yeah by
play on one goal i meant to play for
black white white's just absolutely
absolutely suffering after
the getting into this ending i wasn't
sure about the ritchie game because when
we
got into this ending originally i
thought
it was something that white would be
pressing and i think he still is no
i'm not 100 sure it looks like uh yeah
it looks like he blundered upon with
czech but obviously rook takes a for
checking g3 loses material for black so
actually it doesn't you have rook gt4
but then you will have to play an engine
with a rook on a8 so you don't probably
want oh i have two pawns not six check
yeah i thought yeah yeah knight c6 check
rook takes effort pardon me king g3 rook
d i was seeing the same thing like but
honestly even the truck ending how happy
are you there yes very really sure he's
got an extra punch
okay
yeah a seven king of four
uh why are you so happy here oh because
i've
i've got two i've got i've got four
versus two majority six fifty five five
three
it's probably a draw but it's black
making it i'm pretty sure rook a5
checking before i mean
true
it's it's black making it i think you do
make it with e5 check specifically here
i think i i i've checked it's kind of
the last moment for you to actually make
that before you before rook a6 e5 but
it's very much it's very much black
making it despite being 2. upon up and
two two connected pastors in the center
i'm pretty sure about that but there was
the king c6 in anything yeah but there's
96 check after the yeah which is which
ends the game on the spot yeah yeah
exactly we do have this uh
nasty oopsy daisy uh check
all right
uh alejandro what do you have for us all
right we got this position between mvl
and favi the engine's hating black's
position they think yeah nice sacrifice
but it just doesn't work uh currently
wrote a trick though that is a nice
thing
that's a trick rook f4 was played by
poppy attacking the bishop on h4
and we've been harping about this bishop
coming to g3 and this would be the time
to do it right you attack the rook with
the tempo good job until you find move
queen h3 check oh yeah that's a pretty
funny move
what a trick if you take on h3
that's mate that's actual checkmate you
cannot take this queen uh so bla what is
actually just busted bishop g3 queen h3
check if you go back uh
you go you have to go this way but then
you start getting hunted down and white
loses so rook f4 maxim just has to avoid
the tricks bishop g3 i think is easy
enough for him bishop e1 is the correct
move you have to defend the bishop
somewhere uh and this keeps the g
shockingly
it still works after bishop too
and
it still works after bishop f2 because
there's another five mate
that that's actually beautiful yeah that
is maybe even more beautiful that's
definitely more beautiful check here and
made on i5 that's actually really cool
so bishop f2 doesn't work bishop g3
doesn't work by process of elimination
you put the bishop on e1 but it does say
despite the beautiful tricks as long as
you
the freshman sidesteps them he has a
winning advantage it is a piece and the
engines are thinking this compensation
this tricks they're running out this is
not gonna last your entire game you
can't make tricks and threats all of the
game when you're down a piece eventually
this will simplify and the engines are
giving a plus 2.5 advantage to maxim
it's already pretty huge considering the
position on the border black's pretty
active and the fact that you're only
down technically one pawn
i'm too old because i remember
this game between um olfa anderson
and bill hartston where queen h3
shack
sank
ulf anderson in a position that he was
actually doing very well but bill
harston went on to win the hastings
tournament
in that game but queen
i must say queen h3 is a that's a lovely
victory yeah but the the
unfortunate thing for fabi here is that
it's pretty much impossible to me simply
because rook four if bishop g3 is
playable
rook
of course it is yeah and he knows he's
not playing against an idiot right
so like i want to play bishop g3 and
you're you put your rook there with the
temple you're being you're being
actively provoked to make the best move
in the position there must be a reason
exactly now if bishop e1 the best move
were to appear
uh you're basically saying black is
running out of tricks as beautiful as
they may be bishop a1 on the board and
bishop e1 on the board as uh
expected
um
it feels like there should be some more
tricks in the position
now we can go bishop g3 right
now there's no bishop f1 mate i will
play bishop g3 in this position probably
and no
no trickies with yeah it takes e4 either
oh no in the meantime our very exciting
uh
very uh game ragosa vienna is probably
coming to a close there yeah it seems
that like a lot of attacking games in
chess black defended well
white tried his best to open up the
position but it's simplified and you can
see it on your board three versus three
night against bishop not much to talk
about in this one the players are simply
repeating finding a draw in the drawn
position
but what a fantastic success yeah i want
to say for the local players
again bogdan comes into this event with
a target on his back he says look guys
i've got two and a half out of four i
don't know why you think i'm i'm uh i'm
a weakness this is apparently repetition
number six yeah they're making sure
they're making sure
and uh
wow i mean
great defense yeah playing playing
really really well uh really really
enjoying uh what he's doing so far
speaking of great defense is
uh
is nepo making a great defense here i
mean it's it's a grim defense yeah it's
it's grim but uh not that great it's
it's it's very annoying though because
if white manages to completely tie you
down to the protection of the f7 square
like if i get some kind of a setup in
which i have queen on c4 bishop on d5 i
play e4 and h5 is not hanging currently
wesley is somewhat hamstrung by the
necessity of protecting the h5 pawn
right but let's say we make a couple of
bad moves for black right we go i don't
know queen f6
queen c4 queen e7 bishop d5 right right
and we continue shuffling on the seventh
like queen d7 e4 queen e7 and so on
right white will play f4 e5 uh there
will with the bishop on d5 there's never
really any serious checks to that king
on g2 you can't really launch any kind
of counter attack right you're king and
then the question is can we actually
improve this to the degree that our
advantage becomes decisive
i'm not sure but also i would not like
to be the one sitting there in a great
chair finding out finding out in
practice if there is some way to include
the king somehow or yeah this is this is
very dangerous or or isn't there just
like some and terribly uh or maybe white
low grind where everything just improves
itself magically well perhaps you know
white finds a way to play e6 in such a
way that if the xc6 is forced and then
you actually get mated on the light
squares like e6fe bishop take c6 and
then i reroute the bishop to the b1 h1
the eigen diagonal and create some
mating threats
this is going to be very very annoying
for for jan to hold
i suspect
it's probably not lost and this is where
i wanted to say i want to say even
before the before we went on break that
i'm particularly interested in
kasparov's opinion on this because i
have a feeling he will have uh
as as close to hard knowledge about this
as you can get because he will have
looked at similar stuff over the years
and i would trust his opinion on this
very very much and again that the game
that he did lose in the world
championship manchester against anatoly
karpov would probably
also be very stimulative uh to that uh
again
a matchup of our candidates
how do you reckon the game between for
ruja and
richie has developed we left it just
here i think it's probably closer to
equality than it is to white winning but
it's not that much fun with the outside
passer and the rooks behind it it's
the thing with like
when it's still four rooks on the board
very often you come to these weird
positions where uh the pawn gets quite
far sometimes even to the seventh but
definitely to the sixth year
and then it's get it gets blockaded and
in particular if it gets attacked with
one rook from the side and one rook from
in front like if you put the one rook on
a7 and the other one b6 somehow those
positions are pretty much equal because
white can not really uh break that
exactly
but here it's not clear if if richie
will be in time to get the second rook
to b6 like if we continue the line
you've just shown like rook d7 a6 rook
a7 i go rugby three for instance
i ask you whether you want to allow rp7
check which is probably with the king
only seven the answer probably is no no
you so you play rook i don't know rook
d4 d7 here i play rugby six
and this is this this is a dream set up
that you want
i still don't quite know exactly how we
win this with white
but
it just feels like it's uh yeah rook she
wants he seeks maybe his one idea as he
asserts and yeah yeah he took three
moves to do well somehow you want to
defend e5
when you get to c6 yeah but i agree roxy
won
rook i mean if black ends up really
seizing somehow the defensive uh yeah
completely but then the game starts
running up yeah then the king starts
running up exactly once the king gets he
gets let's say the b5 square you can
trade one player somewhere and win
exactly pretty much win right so this is
not going to be a pleasant defense for
uh foreign he has you you have some
immediate way of not allowing this kind
of a bind which exactly i suspect maybe
there is i i do too i'm not exactly by
the way we do have rook on d8 to d7 on
the board
um
maybe we were about to see asics and uh
what why did we need to play rook uh oh
that was because we wanted to threaten
this one as a
i was
kind of thinking but here we go rook d5
i guess right and we used to create
counter play that is exactly it but
yeah we have we have of the the first
interview of the day christian
kirilla is in a bucharest with shakira
jared
thank you peter yes we are indeed here
with uh chakriarma medyarov after a very
uh tense and comparative uh draw shock
even when you make uh draws still it
seems like the game could go either way
it happened against richard rapport now
it happens again against uh tell us a
bit about your initial feelings after
this game
okay it's problem i just forget my own
preparation
and i start to play just for attack i
want to play for for attack but
i think i played good i mean almost you
played good
it's a more important moment is i think
this game is
when
almost so yeah it was like
so this seemed to have been some sort of
a stem game between gucash and wesley
also of course your game against wesley
as as well
i mean i i just said here is this more
important moment
i don't understand i remember this movie
i don't understand why queen b6 i
remember this very fantastic line uh
bishop f5 knight f8 or g6 98 i mean 93
knight g3
g6 and the amazing group d3
maybe not here
not uh he's before yeah here i mean
immediately after judging
rook
rp3
yes i remember this line i think
it was my home profession like this i
mean i think it's good possession or
just to play king h1 is very strong for
attack
very do you sacrifice this yeah black
i think for humans is losing position i
think you need to take the piece yeah
open up the g5 i i remember this
this line uh but i i cannot understand
how
after queen beat but
bishop f7 is made again
yeah i mean it's i couldn't be it for
this queen b8 i did not play this bishop
b6 i see i forget queen beethoven
of course taken this and what was the
main line that you were
no i i
should have said my miss
for this
bishop f7 of course of course i i need
to play take because i remember this
queen b6 because his first line in g and
just like bishop f6 g6 g63 it's amazing
more working h1
okay it was my idea it's my point to
play
this chess to sacrifice bishop and play
a very beautiful position i was i don't
know okay i finished in this position my
home professional i think i will play
this one is a very nice position yeah no
very difficult yeah yeah yeah yeah
for sure of course and uh but i don't
understand queen b8 i miss this
point queen b8 bishop f7 but after okay
i think okay better to play h4
and i don't know why were you at all
worried that i might just be upon down
and not be able to recover it
yeah but this problem is it is very
strange you know is my my
mistake is sometimes i sacrifice pawn
and after two moves i try to play very
slowly
it is too late to place very solid i of
course the bishop d3 is not bad but i
need to play some g5 move why not plays
g5 a is really not easy to take you like
to not maybe take yeah maybe take maybe
bishop d3 that's to play these positions
amazing interesting position take knight
h5 uh why not to this position i mean
no three points okay it's a little bit
more it's not three yeah three for the
moment
okay it's no no problem one or two or g
one yeah but this i think is winning
position for what this
again
i play bishop d3 i think it's okay first
i will play bishop literally after g5
they miss absolutely sixth move because
e60 he cannot not take g5 of course
first g5 let's to g5 and this is amazing
position take and bishop d3
this amazing position yeah and i think
it's very very interesting and white is
fantastic strong attack but
i i just miss this idea b6
after b6 okay i think is okay now
how to play not tools game
because exactly it did feel at some
point that he
everything pretty tightly and
i think it was alejandro that was
showing this variation with knight to d7
right here
was that a move that you consider no no
i but i i understand there's no attack
here i mean i absolutely understand this
like his position is good but uh i think
it's also after queen g7 is good because
uh first i missed is kung ji for check
bishop g6 bishop e4 is very strong idea
because it was my point take take and
just to play knight h5 but here he is 97
i'm a king nice game yeah i miss it i
think knight h5 still is white is okay
but i miss 97 because his bishop b5 or
bishop just king of eight king seven and
it is easy to lose this position
and uh for white yeah of course i mean
it's a very good chance because
uh you sacrifice palm for attack not for
defense yeah absolutely and this pawn on
d4 is extremely dangerous once it gets
free and the uh queen g4 knight g6
bishop before it's a good move because
of the rook b8
maybe rook c7 but his end game is also
not easy to play
i mean this is very active
night and day it was my point no two
points but his knight everything is good
kg2 one idea and he is no problem after
bishop before is okay safe
position
is draw i mean just
yes it was it was the main point i
forget
your uh analysis yeah and after okay i
forget but i played not bad i was it
looks good but after is very important
moment i miss this b6 move maybe i need
to immediately g5 to think about
attack but i want to just improve my
position bishop and after the next move
g5 that was late shaq a pretty difficult
uh start to the tournament what do you
feel needs to change for you to get back
in the groove of course it's not easy
when you start tournament with rules
game but
i played two interesting games and the
result is not wearable but i deserve it
because i played really not very good
just i try to play good chess
interesting chess
uh
okay as well more five games not every
year you can play good in bucharest and
sometimes it's also
normal to play bad in bucharest is it's
very good i mean for me is a certain
normal i just try and injure from chess
and every game i tried to play four win
but still not win one game that is okay
but
why not we try
despite the results still very
entertaining to us uh thank you very
much for joining us and we'll see you in
the next few rounds thank you very much
guys
thank you uh christian thank you shaq
and we just have to rejoin the game
between the lanier and lavonne aronian
and through the magic of television
he played that is to say lanier a move
with one second
on his clock and he it's so nicely so
gracefully look how he just oh well
well within the second question
one second no
no issues in control yeah completely
under control yeah bit of
one second one second unfortunately for
lanier he may have uh made that
particular move with one second muskog
but his position is not good he's yeah
he's still he's still much worse
whether
it's not easy to win these types of
positions because the king on h8 like
with the ball on f7 and slightly better
carotenation you would feel that you
know the win is
uh semi-automatic but uh with the king
on h8 slightly uh uncomfortable and
potential rookie six con to play maybe
later is
you can see how you may actually fail to
win this with black but of course it's a
reasonably healthy extra pawn for for
levon and a bishop against knight in a
reasonably open position if he
consolidates if whites
i kind of hesitate to call this
initiative because there's really not
very much initiative here but
uh if he has some kind of a grip let's
say which is why i actually kind of
prefer bishop c5 to bishop c3 i think
the bishop c3 looks like a very nice
square but i think c5 is a more relevant
square and it also pretty much
completely stops rookie 6 because you
can play rook d1 check
and king h2 bishop d6 would be a bit of
a mistake even though bishop rookie
check exists but i i will play queen g8
there
and be very happy that
you're getting your queen back i am
guessing i am getting a queen back with
you just yeah uh so bishop c5
to
forestall rook e6 yeah i want to support
it with b7 b6 and then eventually kind
of come out of the core and perhaps you
know ideally play queen f7 king g7 and
then eventually we will start improving
with with all the entrance squares
covered into our position the bishop on
c5 still does a very good job dominating
the knight on f3 so i'm expecting this
square to be chosen but we'll see what
the one does very good and just checking
in on the wesley soul game not much has
changed we wouldn't have expected a lot
to be changed only that wesley continues
to
just make life that much more unpleasant
for his opponent richie
this is the moment where we suspect
yeah the big question about rook b3 is i
kind of confidently predicted rook d5
allows rugby to prog b7 check i mean it
does allow it but maybe we can because
there's king d8 there in the end i
thought it was very strong but i'm not
sure rook d5 and if the check does
happen we can take take play rugby five
rook a seven king d8 without king d8 we
would be losing on the sport but king g8
gets our king actually close enough to
the b pawn so that it doesn't queen
and then maybe we are not doing that
poorly with our gun to play against the
e5 pawn mm-hmm
um we'll see we'll see
but i think it's important for for
richie in the current position to be
creating counter threats with every move
because as we've described if you give
white time to establish some kind of a
control with one rook on b6 the other
one potentially all the way to c6
that one that one you don't like so you
you would like to be able to
uh to at least ask a question and ruby
five definitely does ask the question
notably ruby 3 hasn't been played yet
exactly exactly
this is the current position and uh
for rougia how much time it's hard for
me to tell
plenty i think considering it's more 35
i think it's although i mean it's
actually not such a simple end game it's
like minutes
five minutes okay well it's more than he
normally has for a full chess game i
wanted to say like for yeah yeah for a
vast majority of his
and uh
he
well i mean you gotta you gotta give the
guy credit fabiano is trying his best to
cheapo uh mvl um
and mvl has played about as solidly as
he possibly he sees the defensive but is
there any way for fabi to increase what
looks like i don't see it tricks
i don't see it i don't see it either and
the engine doesn't as well the move
queen f5 was rather cagey because after
queen f5 well bishop g3 still doesn't
work
um but it does try to create threats
rook takes e4 and queen f1 being the
major source of counterplay so maximus
up for a little bit play the most
accurate move absolutely necessary to
play 92 but now you're ready now you're
ready to put the bishop on g3 f1 has
been covered uh you're also threatening
the bishop on c4 you can take that in
many occasions where's the counter play
the bishop's coming to g3 i'm getting
that solid position finally and it seems
that black doesn't have enough resources
to prevent white from solidifying the
position and being up a piece of a piece
here is just no compensation
wow
all right well uh there you go that's
that's the problem
we're a piece down yeah that's very much
either it cracks the crux of our problem
there exactly just putting our finger
right on the on the issues uh again i
find myself drawn to the game of ferugia
because i do believe this is
in many ways
a key a key moment
if there's something to be said could i
play
as a preliminary five first you have to
stop looking at this yeah stop rook d5
and prep
all of those ideas of rook b3 and rook
b6 and rook c5 and rook c6 what do you
think about them apples the one thing
i'm trying to do yeah takes 66 years
looks winning and totally right this
would be a this would be a dream come
true don't do that
do
what he has played rook a5 yeah
so it's a good call
for first time in four rounds by the way
i get to use my favorite cheapo these
guys are good
they see a lot uh does the computer
think it's anything no
alejandro is just shaking his head you
know the accuracy you know the engine
zero zero zero zero zero zeros yeah
rookie five was one of the many attempts
that furuja had in this position and
there's a couple of ways to keep let's
say equality honestly uh white is always
going to be the one pressing this
position but the engines are just not
afraid of it one of them is that they
see your they see your plans of playing
rook c6 or b5 rook v6 they don't want to
allow you to do that so one way to
prevent it first you can just bring the
king closer to d7 that covers the c6
square
there's no easy way to re-maneuver white
species the king can never come in
because it's just completely cut off by
the rook on d4 you don't have access to
the c6 square if you move the rook
further to the b file i can continue
chasing uh your rook with king c7 and of
course this rook is currently stuck to
defending the pawn a6 so there's no
progress to be made uh another way to do
it yes you want to get the b file for
your rooks uh no
how about my rooks right and if you go
rook c6 i can start giving you checks
the king is also not very well placed it
doesn't have a lot of hiding spots uh in
many cases you can start counter play
with moves like g5 h5 g4 and by the time
that you've gotten some kind of setup
here well i've taken all of your king's
side right so it's not so easy for
furuja to just create uh counterplay uh
on the clean side that way so k7 and
rook before the engines are saying are
both fine i have the feeling that even a
move like no g5 just loses to rook h3
this one is
oops this one i forgot about but
most most moves the g6 work yeah the
problems are actually on the third rank
so you need to be solving those issues
first rook b4 does it by checking you
almost infinitely on this file the other
version king d7 and once you put your
rook here i'm going to have king c6 the
rook on a7 defense the king side i think
d7 is a more logical move i like this
move because it prevents the rook coming
to c6 but the engines think there's more
than one way to split this point all
right uh thank you very much for that
aleandra we just had a
kind of a desperado move i think by uh
fabi he got
pretty he's pretty low on time yeah
having about what two minutes or so for
about a dozen yeah our screen says our
screen says somewhat somewhat less than
three minutes yeah he played yeah four
on the board and
bishop g3 mbl will quite happily give up
the pawn f3 to put his king on f2 and
use the f3 pawn as shield
uh excuse me how do we do that if we
take on him i think he goes king of two
here
e f king f2 because of course i was
dreaming
of
d5 rook f3 action i think we'll start
with rick f3 yeah i do it this way
yeah that would be disastrous
absolutely disastrous
clearly not intending to start
blundering here he's
avoided this so far in this game
it's a binge one check i thought was
mate but it's not
that was my problem i thought quinji won
queen g2 sorry quincy took in g1 is
actually giving giving mate but i do
have the e4 square
and you want to play f2 but f2 is really
completely empty because we control the
f1 square i can just take on if i can
just take on default with the queen or
whatever exactly exactly wow
okay that's a little bit crazy but and
if the rook has to go somewhere and then
i will take on f3 i suppose like rook g4
i think i can reasonably safely take on
f3 with the knight i'm i'm so worried
about you taking my bishop well yeah all
night take c4 actually is a better is a
better way king f2 on the board and what
is uh actually
mvl's time i've lost enough time he has
14 minutes he's got plenty of time
against the two minutes king f2
by the way i mean it's a little like
fabby keeps playing all of his cards you
know like you know trump trump trump
trump and uh mbl has just
responded the time and uh really really
well
and he sees the defense of like a pro
yeah
seems to be fizzling uh he's running out
of things to do to throw
yeah i mean
where's where's the kitchen sink i need
i need something else you know you turn
to your opponent your partner and say
dude i need a rook
yeah
yeah
i'm pretending i'm a bug house player
i'm very much not a bug house player
if you give it well enough you keep it's
like you've been around i can stand next
to people playing bug house and pretend
yeah that's okay okay it's very
important because there's always there's
always some refreshment next to the
buckhouse table and this is why i'm
there
i'm not playing a show back house i'm
just you know using using the fridge
nearby okay uh you gotta keep on this
one 50 seconds
h3
one more look because it's just so much
fun to see a king you know strutting its
stuff up the board is not fun and here
you still have c5 oh
still lc5 it's lost but okay that's fun
but you know you you challenge it's not
trivial
yeah but when you do this what what
about knight f5 check for just a sec 25
seconds
but to be fair queen h3 the main problem
with queen h3 is that you just take on
f3 and there's absolutely nothing
like that yeah
that's terrible so king f2 he has
he has ducked queen h3 which we think
came up empty-handed because of knight
bishop
but rook g4
there was a there was a booing yeah i'm
assuming pretty much anything wins here
i might see if we'll be able to
frequency for check and then there's
just no threats we can just start
developing rook c1 next move or
something precisely so i mean
the most obvious move is the winning
move but it is not it is the only move
for some reason knight c4s yeah pretty
much there's other moves like b3 that
keep an advantage but if you want a
winning advantage you got to take that
bishop that being said who doesn't take
that bishop that's the problem i mean
it's just such an er
what what
it's that bishop that has been causing
all of the uh conflicts
in a white setup and knight takes c4
looks
well i mean
pretty pretty good for white yeah yeah
and we we might be
you know it might be that time in the
show when we can you know seed ground to
somebody who is
has actually been good at chess for for
quite some time and uh is still you know
master of his domain but i don't know if
it's if it's immediately right now or
perhaps slightly later but that is
definitely something to look forward to
as gary will join our show
uh before too long uh what else do you
have for us alejandro
has uh
anything happen in some of the other
matches are we just going to keep
our eye on this one i think we just keep
an eye on this one because favi
i mean if if knight 64 comes i assume it
will come relatively quickly mm-hmm
if i will have to come up with a couple
of ideas right you take on c4 queen
takes before they can go somewhere
and then
i i really do like roxy one just
yeah
just because it's just so difficult to
create a threat knight e2 is very empty
because i will but if your rook goes to
yeah i will have quincy five there oh
man i will have cracks
uh rooksy one we're just looking at this
nice little double attack that peter
clears the cobwebs with the move queen
c5 it just doesn't feel like we have
enough attack like the bishop on g3
covers so many important avenues of
potential problems that you know exactly
just doesn't feel like it's anything
nope
and as we're enjoying our uh first stop
of the grand chess tour in bucharest we
have four more store stops uh peter
absolutely the one coming right on the
heels of this one is a rapid blitz in in
warsaw which will basically see all of
these players with a couple of additions
uh uh travel to warsaw poland and uh
play five days of rapid employees
starting on the 17th and ending i
believe on the 23rd and then we have a
rapid blitz in zagreb uh which is in
july and as usual the tour will get
uh rounded up by with the two
tournaments here in saint louis first
these includes rapid and blitz
which will go uh in the last week of
august and then in immediately after
that there is a single cup which will uh
run in
the first couple of weeks of september
we'll also have the fischer wrap at the
fisher
uh
fish are random i wanted to say that
thanks
9lx that's right very good very good i
like it and magnus
obviously as you saw there in the
graphic magnus joining our tour as a
wild card player for a zagreb and
interestingly unveiled took on c4 and
then took on f3 which is something we
did not discuss but which also which is
also something that looks pretty good
let me just refresh my board i apologize
knight takes e4 getting rid of that
nasty bishop
completely ruining black's pawn
structure and bishop takes f3
pretty good that's it right that's
really good
oh
boy that is also very efficient yeah
just getting rid of that that pesky pawn
on f3 opening up the rook on a1 to come
into let's say f1 and then king g2 jitu
somehow somehow this has echoes of their
game of last year where favi also played
the spanish also had some kind of crazy
novelty and at some point had good ideas
and
overextended
he overextended played the wrong move
order right that was with the queen on
the kings side riding messed up yeah
getting messed up and in that game mvl
didn't get quite enough for a winning
advantage the game i think fizzled out
to a draw but
this time
there's still one or two questions left
because if you if you give if you don't
play queen e2 i will take on b2 it's
slightly annoying if you do play queenie
so i give a check back from a five
minute g2 yeah and then i go h5h4 and i
kind of
pretend to have something is this stage
is still there
a case once more queen takes v2 rook f1
let's say rock g6 and uh i mean you only
have two left in these positions you
don't actually resign because there's
like if somehow the a2 pawn gets picked
up which i don't really see how it
happens after qd5 check maybe rook g5 is
slightly more precise actually to stop
that from happening
you have queen f7 right exactly i'm
picking up the c4 yeah i mean i'm i'm
obviously clutching us at straws here
we know this is
technically winning but white has fewer
few enough pawns to have
like a semblance of chance here exactly
which is why we
rather like to keep our b2 pawn from the
very get-go and play the move queen e2
which is something that you return to f5
no i mean it's still winning i'm sure
yeah and then
wherever the king goes i want to play
h5h4
but after rook f1 i assume it's like
it's never fast enough we we know from
experience that these things are just
never fast enough
and we finally do have that that segment
of the show you've been promising we've
been promising and the one that i i like
very much because i i do enjoy listening
to gary talk about chess christian
gorilla is with gary kasparov let's go
to bucharest
thank you guys promised and always
delivered i am indeed with uh a legend
here the 13th world champion gary
kasparov gary welcome back to the studio
uh i called you a legend also yesterday
we lost a legend yuri averbach uh passed
away tell us a little bit about that
your experience and your relationship
with him
oh look it's really legend
it's 100 years whole century
so
we had little discussion just you know
recalling uh
uh of our encounters ravelbach and i
said as the man was the
soviet national champion back in 1954
and uh
i played twice with him yesterday thank
you for having this picture so march
1974
so i was 10 and it was the
match of uh
baku moscow this is the um it's all
called the grand master and pioneers
when the captain of uh one team uh gave
a simultaneous simultaneous to another
team and our captain played against
their team
and uh that was my it was a round three
i lost the first two games to talon
polovsky but here you know thanks to our
bach mistake in the opening so i grabbed
the pawn and managed to
keep the pawn without spoiling my
position until um
move 45 then you
uh the game was adjourned and there was
the uh the result
was awarded by by captains so and and i
remember i overlooked bagheera forever
yeah uh moving the pieces
and uh yeah now by the way when i look
at the computer just understand
it's a it's a it's a it's a tricky end
game it's extra pawn but
computer
finds it quite difficult for for white
to win but i remember one day we talked
about it and i just okay
and uh saying come on
hearing
so it's extra pawns do you mind
so i was i wasn't one awarded uh uh this
victory and um and second time we played
in 1982 uh uh
in the soviet team championship um
uh and uh i managed to win an end game
so it's just interesting because it's a
preaching end game and uh playing his
album you know this is the man who was
the most recognized authority on end
games and uh
and his books hooks and games
yeah exactly this is it's online games
it was something that he knows was like
a mandatory so
and um
and uh
we
i i put him under pressure
uh eventually i got extra pawn and it
was an end game rook and bishop went
five pawns
when i looked at the game uh saw nippon
so same as five pawns you know this d e
f g h versus four points e f g h we
would definitely discuss
rook and bishop versus
rook and knight and i wasn't sure
whether it's you know it's it's you can
win but the extra pawn and manage yeah
just to to uh improve my position and i
won the game
and of course you know he was a
referee in in in in my match with was
was memory of your match exactly
actually yes yes but oneness was
corporal that's that's as i i should
recall and uh and we always have very
very good good relations with the event
was you know
the last of my cons someone who who came
from the soviet union but never had the
same you know like soviet stamp on him
so he was you know it's so quiet with
independent mind and uh
oh you know the man just
was a little wisdom uh but also
fairly
quiet and it's not
not all um
pressing here just to to accept his
authority though again his age you know
make him uh
more
uh demanding in in in uh uh in respect
to his to his these opinions but
yeah it's
he was such a universal man as well he
had a different career but also within
chess he had he wore a lot of hats in
which role would you say he made the
biggest impact for russian trust as well
as for the world of chess
look it's very different difficulty to
separate from history universal games or
soviet chairs russian chess or global
chess
so he was a great chess player uh uh he
left you know his is uh his mark i mean
in the openings of avalor system and in
against king's indian
uh and um
also of course end games
and i think it's just it's it's less you
know known but his role was just
historic so some of the phenomenal works
and just actually i suggest to you know
for those who are interested to read his
research of the
of the ancient chess so the chess played
the chatrance chairs and and the
transformation of chess from chatrance
to to to the multi-modal jazz some
really phenomenal works so i always
enjoyed reading it and it's a it's it's
he because he was very scrupulous and
and you know it's it's meticulous in
collecting details and
and uh
some of these books you know just they
they can give you an idea so how much
has transformed you know just from one
very slow motion uh medieval game that
was a reflection of the of the military
strategy at the time into some far more
dynamic and more modern european
absolutely and you were mentioning this
uh big end game between uh wesley and
nepo and actually peters viller in the
studio wanted your opinion on this
really wanted to know how you feel that
his chances look like for wesley so to
win this game
it seems unlikely to me because
uh
yeah if you could have put it [ __ ] when
d5 and fourth black queen on f6 so then
that's f6 or e7 maybe yes but then maybe
there will be the chance but the problem
is you know
h5 was always hanging so
yeah and he was uh
that pawn on h5 is there for a while but
it wasn't forced
to go there but maybe this position he
had more chances
yeah h5 was very tempting but the
problem is you know so how are you going
to
improve the solution
maybe e4 f4 85 something that's that's
that's something that you want to do so
that's the
again h5 was a very uh demanding move so
if you play h5 you have to be sure that
you know that's that's that's you you
you do next i mean in theory ideally if
you had let's say h5 and then to play e4
and then f4 e5 yeah that's that's that
will be that'll be good so it's easy and
break with e6 and somehow have yeah
maybe you have to start with with with
e4 so yeah
to make sure that you know this is yeah
e4 because now it's just easy to attack
and now the computer says g5 but that's
not a move uh
f4 first yeah that's so that's
definitely an option but then h5 yes h5
and then e4 say i put my pawns like this
e5
easy
at least i won the pool
but you just was sacrificing you do yeah
yeah take king g7 and cover with queen
of six
so that's that's that
shows that black has resources so that's
why you so played h5 and now maybe if
you were to play e4 yeah yeah that would
be more far more dangerous yeah yes
because then then sacrificing this pawn
on f7 is more dangerous because black
king would be problem but immediately he
played the queen of five two five
immediately get the bishop out of v5
you know it's interesting they don't
just again speaking with abu bakr and
games you know it's it's
it seems very simple i mean this is but
but there's so many nuances so it's the
because in the end game
even in such you know
um
[Music]
simplistic looking simplistic looking uh
angular and a few pieces but there's so
many details you seem to try h5 and then
e4 and f4 and every time you know this
is the
slide change you know uh uh um
requires uh a new strategy because e4
you play g5 and f4 you play h5 yes h5
you attack the pawn so it's it's it's
yeah it's it's
yeah and i uh i think that's probably
this this is the position currently this
is what we have and it sounds like they
can do something because it's just the
end i don't see how bishop can come on
d5
with the attack on the corner
excellent so this one let's say we
believe that nepal can hold it now by
the way that's that's also that's this
it was another catalan yeah it was
another catalan and it's it seems that
now this is the they play italian with
reverse color and then
yeah so uh this must be something yeah
exactly
yeah i i find a little bit odd that
sacrificing the pawn but seems that you
know he he didn't get what he wanted uh
because it's uh it was not his dream i'm
sure he thought he could make an easy
draw but some also managed to to to
to keep the point with something but but
probably he he should try do something
else you know because you know
uh he also had rooks
yeah maybe he would have kept maybe try
to keep the rooks as much as possible
excellent let's uh jump into this game
the one between mvl because this one
actually is about to finish mostly
normal game anymore yes what happened
here was yeah
this big point right now yeah this it's
first you know this is they they play
very quickly
so many games now is played quickly and
and that's that's that's one of the one
of the topics
was opened um
lopez and that's the phoenix line knight
f2 so this is
i think he played against switzerland in
1941
yeah
and um and now this is it's uh
when i play chess everybody took on fc
automatically but now they do something
you know so they they they decided to
try to form yes yes yes knight f1
therefore fight like king g1 yes so um
and 27 so that's this
uh
information
i think this was the move that surprised
yes
mvl he played uh very strange
if i have prepared for the game so this
is like i don't look at queen d7 so it's
the natural move because somehow
we should g5 uh rookie 8
22.
another very long thing and d4 i think
was played
yes
natural move so let's do it
see there's nothing wrong with the move
so and uh
he played uh knight to g3
h6
and bishop to h464 and dc3
and that's critical position yes okay so
when after 94 uh
yeah what happened before
it seems like maybe knight takes e5
queen to d6 knight g6
take on c to take on c2 and now the
corrupts will have some of the simple
route to f7
just taking advantage of the awkwardness
let's say of the placement in white
spaces
it's probably yeah but no way it's a bit
a bit odd yes so the
probably blackest yeah and he thought
for a very long time actually
and he took on f3 15 minute thing 50
minutes is it that's amazing she takes a
free into 94 and he giving me
probably he calculated bishop to e4 this
is what we think yeah we're definitely
going to ask him yeah about it um bishop
to d5
and now
probably black has a lot of compensation
for the piece once peace
why did he sacrifice white sacrifice
that is a very good question
there's no unless you win by force and
it didn't seem that you win by force and
uh why it's this position was so
comfortable yeah hooks it's open
bishop on a schwarz very awkward i don't
know i'm just like so and that's that's
that's this was the big miss but also i
want to yeah
point you to this moment afterwards
let's spend the emails spent three
minutes i'm just not to not to not to be
not to uh
be caught in the truck we should reach
the queen h3 mate yes right
but that's you know that's that's that's
okay i wouldn't say it's so typical but
still you could you could find it
understandable yes but um yes we could
find it in in
in
in some chess games or just studies but
but that's what i like more you know
queen h3
and now
that's more more more unusual
is that yeah that's yeah but okay it's
the unveil founders the this
[ __ ] of the strap and then the bishop
okay and now the
last few tries that
before the simplification and it just
seems like
there's not much left for mbl at this
point queen to f7 followed by queen to
h5 seems to be finishing that game
i don't think you'll go
why should you go this is why not bishop
c3 also
so this one we are not giving any
chances unfortunately for fabiano uh
this game
was quite wild at the beginning the one
between the president why do i this is
this is the line that i analyzed it in
1985
before my
second match against corporal because i
i already had in mind of playing uh uh
swastikas justice d and uh so for black
you analyze this
for black and uh and actually i
when i had my um
first professional cyborg against uh hhs
v team in hamburg in december i played
this uh you know i just had eight board
simul and the reverse color so this
because i insisted i would play black
and white so this is the uh as a team so
i played this line against uh chandler
actually it's i i don't remember the
game with this but that was our idea
actually queen b6 and after i think d1
we're planning we're planning this is
the the uh somehow we thought it would
be in just interesting uh um
idea to uh to play the to play the line
because we saw that the ideas c5 g5 so
uh
that's exactly what just because queen
b6 this is the move that just to
interrupt you mvl did uh win that game
it seems like they're discussing they're
trying to understand what went wrong for
fabiano right now
uh
he seems confused probably just bishop
to d1 but let's get back to our analysis
yeah so and because it's the it's the
queen mistakes i think it was quite a
new move at the time so i
i got a decent position but you know it
still was the game though but because
difficult to manage in the simultaneous
it didn't seem like but he played bishop
here and and and and again here just is
the what i would do after you should be
two i would definitely g5 yeah this is
that's what i would
and uh and after fg5 so this is
interesting so because we have
we have now h4 and queen b8
and critical mode
no
just try to win this pawn and then this
is the that's what we discussed this is
the same game
yeah so it's like a middle game
d5 and uh some sort of uh structural
imbalances yes yes structural balances
here so
yeah it's uh probably it's it's
maybe d5 maybe actually c5 will never
know maybe c5 also that's another chance
g4 and the castle
yes
and i do think that uh
richard actually was aware of these
ideas with g5 because he played quite
quickly rook to d8 and here again you
have the option of playing g5 with the
same idea but he decided quite quickly
to play knight c8 that's i don't know
this is this knight doesn't belong there
so that's the baby
seem to be thinking at this point
and against c5 critical move only move
in the position wow
now you spend time because you know just
it's uh
yeah but he spent time here he didn't he
did this was the first moment where he
spent some but how he used to play this
line with queen e5 this is only movies
cfo only moved only moved c5 and he
found it
and he found it and then
well we entered in this endgame in which
it didn't seem like any of the sides
managed to get anything and right now we
have this position uh
the a pawn looks very threatening the
problem is you have to face some
perpetuals on this exactly there's two
rooks yes it's the two rooks well this
is still an interesting game very
interesting game yes very interesting
but do you remember yesterday we we all
we called ferrari's game with aronia oh
my goodness
oh my goodness yeah
yeah
study like
there was a study like yeah at the end
with the fact that you know this
iranians survived as far as as as the
position that was you know study-like
yeah
tells you that verus's ending technique
needs a little bit of refinement are you
worried uh for uh him and his chances
are the candidates based on his first
three games four games look i i'm not
his coach to worry about him but he
should worry about his performance and
that's the i mean the game that he
played yesterday and by the way before
he did before yesterday
this game demonstrated that uh
he
he could spend his time more
productively and
then probably starting only openings
again it's my educated guess uh over the
last five months well i'm definitely uh
sure that he's watching the broadcast
and we'll take those he doesn't have to
watch broadcast he just looks
listening to me you should look at these
games you know so that's true both
at the moves he made and the results
that he achieved absolutely and the last
game
is this one dominguez versus aronian in
which dominguez actually quite a few
times i think for the last 15 moves
before they reached time control he was
playing with 30 seconds on his clock
he's lucky that there's not much you
know happening that's happening so
yeah so we're only got an extra pawn yes
extra pawn how are his chances in
this position pawn
and this was the move that he played
with one second on the clock
knight to e5
and now we have this position
it's a pawn
it does seem like he has to find and how
are we doing on time okay 18 minutes and
he's really pondering his options now
how can he go wrong knight to e1 we see
the engine is saying that we're still
within some sort of a balanced situation
but what other tempting plans does white
have at least
what does that plan
the only plan they have is is to survive
to survive they probably have to do just
two
i mean trying to to to stay you know
stay put so maybe 91 knight to
91 maybe back 199
you won't have for free but
it's uh and perhaps something like queen
d7 rook f7 rook e7
how will that end game
and rook f7 knight f4 in
but knight four is not an easy move to
take with a g pawn yeah but still it's
this is it's you want to survive so you
don't try to win and he's a great
defender linear and defender but paul
does a point on his opponent and there's
definitely going to be some pressure on
his time as well well
17 gary that's the second time control
he hasn't played this no i bet i would
be able to live on this game levon on
this game
perfect gary when are we going to see
you uh next time on the grand chester
broadcast uh
not live because i'm i'm flying out
tomorrow but i'll be watching it so and
uh you know thanks to modern
technologies so we can communicate you
know even without my physical presence
in the studio excellent looking forward
to see you next week thank you very much
guys back to you thank you christian and
thank you gary and uh meanwhile we do
have a result uh
scored his first victory over a very uh
difficult opponent anaconda a very big
win uh win today for for mbl uh beating
uh beijing fabi who came very well
prepared in that line but then went uh
went astray in the tactical
complications and this is the current
score with some games still of course
ongoing exactly uh mvl uh on top of the
leaderboard and plus one as is uh bogdan
dayak also finished his game the game
between uh wesley and jan is still
uh in progress if wesley wins he will be
uh clear first exactly and he's still
nursing the advantage of an extra pawn
and he's made progress he's managed to
trade his h5 pawn for the g7 part rather
unpro
provoke the uh or or not provoke but
he'll achieve somehow
he has achieved
i don't want to say the maximum because
uh well we always
it's reaching for more and more and more
yeah it's an interesting question
whether this trade actually favors white
or not because on the one hand you have
you have obviously compromised your king
side situation a little bit but on the
other you've given yourself a g7 square
for the king and you have reduced the
number of pawns on the board very simply
put so it's true uh
it's it's a somewhat controversial
decision we were slightly surprised on
break while listening to gary talk about
the other positions we were slightly
surprised that
jan chose this exact moment to do this
because it didn't seem like
that was that would be that would be the
last time he ever had the opportunity to
play g6 but he clearly felt that uh you
know the threat of getting stuck with
the pawn on g7 forever if white actually
does get the bishop all the way to g5
was too strong uh wesley obviously will
continue for for as long as he likes and
eventually eventually the central pawns
will start climbing up the board you
can't win this mission with white
without getting the pawns to f4 and d5
and then perhaps the threats will
materialize
but
you can you can wait for as long as you
like
before doing that yeah the dream being
that we put our bishop on b1 for example
we put our queen on c2
we're constantly patrolling we're trying
to create a battery
and
like okay before this last move by yeah
and if
i could just make a bad move for example
this is more or less a dream i want to
say but even that doesn't really do that
much yeah i mean queen g7 would be
would not be a move i would like to i
like it on f6 i would play something
like bishop e7 on bishop g7 uh because
q7 check really uh as long as we control
the h8 square cleaning so it's not the
same
yeah it's just you can just sidestep it
like this
all right we'll definitely keep an eye
on that as we get a prep for an
interview with mvl and ask him about
these tactical uh
uh
complications that he had in his game
with absolutely it's interesting to see
if he thought he was doing well
throughout or if he was uh
worried at any point for for me i must
say that it's a pretty darn confounding
game because so
much of the game had been so very well
played up to this moment
by by fabiano and we actually thought
well let's say the engine taught us that
the move b5b4 in this particular
position might have given
black and edge absolutely and
i think it's very very difficult to to
judge this it was difficult for us
unplugged to judge what's going on there
and i think
even for for mbl and of course you
always have a better clue of what's
going on on the board when he actually
the one playing the game but even for
him i suspect he was kind of operating
on a move-by-move basis he knew queen
takes e3 was the best move and it really
didn't matter that much to him whether
he was better or worse if it's really
the best decision he can make
but yeah i'm very interested in that
interview
and your conjecture being that the move
bishop d1 was just kind of missed the
strength of this
was missed by fabiano fabi uh pursued a
number of
attempting tactics uh but they all felt
to not and uh he came out with a big
zero one fantastic uh tactic yeah that
was that was really uh he spots it very
nicely by peter was this unusual
checkmate featuring queen h3 and another
five yeah that was
that was
visual
i mean clearly it's not but
it's about as close as you can get in a
practical game to an ideal mate where
every single black piece is
participating in the attack even though
there's five pawns on the board which
can be removed but yeah still like that
one you need for a practical game it's a
very very unusual construction and a
very beautiful one
and again as we're just waiting for set
up from bucharest
in our in our remaining games we just
saw gary uh correctly point out that a
pawn is a pawn in this one
uh
and i would also echo his echoes his
sentiment that
uh you probably take levon to win this
simply because it's just very difficult
to continue not making mistakes and
defending a position like this where
your counter play is you know limited to
non-existent because e7 square will
forever be covered by the bishop on c5
meaning that beautifully and this is
about as active as earpieces can get
right and you need to balance uh
all this with you know
the necessity not to blunder a 504
somewhere which will open the king size
and just give black a crushing attack
you probably don't want to allow any
trades like if the rooks come off
black's conversion probably becomes
simpler if the queens come off i think
the position immediately becomes
technically winning i don't think it's
especially because there's an a2 pawn i
just don't see how that happens very
easily but if the queens do come off i
think
you kind of know you've lost you you
will of course still continue fighting
but you kind of know your your causes
uh your cause is hopeless um and he's
also clearly burning time yet again he's
down half an hour and that will be the
the eternal time trouble when it comes
you know this this one never ends yeah
and we saw again uh
lanier uh making a move in the first
time control with a mere second on his
clock he did it rather elegantly
like it was no problem but yeah for
lavon this is
uh
fantastic considering the last two games
uh yesterday we considered his
his situation
close to hopeless well he wanted to say
he was hopeless yeah and he managed to
draw and now today he's on
the sunny side as we would like to say
alejandro
sunnyside is good but let's go back to
another game that we thought
really held a lot of interest and we
analyzed it a little bit with peter in
this rook end game and i just went a
little bit deeper with the engine and
what's going on here between ali reza
and richard we have them with rook a3
played covering the third rank of course
this is a soft thread of rook c3 rook
cc2 was played and we were wondering
during break if this was the
best and most direct way to make a draw
for black you are throwing a perpetual
the king doesn't have anywhere to hide
so to prevent the perpetual alireza
played a very clever move to move rook
dd3
giving him a little bit of space hiding
behind this rook to avoid the perpetuals
on the fourth rank so if you go check
which happened in the game king e3
i assume king e3 yeah king e3 uh the
king is going to be hiding on the four
many variations and i was playing around
with this trying to mate
wide or combining threads on how to
continue and the correct continuation is
only rook bc2 and that was what
surprised me about the position is that
only the move rook bc2 fully works there
are other moves for example you could
start this way and i was trying to
checkmate peter here with the move rook
vc2 try not um
trying to get rookie four in but the
engine says rook dc3 and you're not
getting in not only your per pet you're
not catching the pawn nah you're not
catching the pawn you have to play down
a rook and capture a bunch of pawns and
hope for the best does not work spoiler
alert so you actually have to play
checking e3 and rook bc2 play it on this
move order first so that if anything
like this happens
you can just take
and go rookie to get the rook behind the
pawn and draw the position this way so
and this is just basically it's the same
position but just with a very important
extra tempo because the king is on e3
and not on d4 just for
uh for clarity and that tempo just
changes from
well it's not just that right you think
with the key you take with the king of
the other parties right in this position
um
that i went here yeah if you go rogue
dc3 and you take i actually take with
the king and you don't have a way to
protect against the pawn you're out of
the square of the pawn so you cannot
trade on uh e3 and a3 so this is lost
for the black pieces rook dd3 is on the
board richard calculating his variations
it's already moved 41 so he can dedicate
a serious amount of thought on what's
the most precise but he has to find the
only way to fully draw the position
check
and then rook bc2 and the point of rook
bc2 because we just kind of uh gloss
over it is that uh if you put this on
on the board for a sec after check rook
bc2 the idea of course is if you play a7
here rook fe2 king g4 runs into a slight
problem mate [ __ ] problem but it is
still a draw if you go this way which is
kind of yeah of course but yeah you need
to take away the squares on the c file
creating the thread of rookie to check
and then rookie for mate if you continue
along the way that you've prepared for
yourself and
help me out here aleandra because i'm
still struggling here uh after
uh rooksy two i've got this position
uh
you played
let's say rogue dc3 rook dc we're taking
the gold rocket why don't i just play
rook here
where's here uh pardon me rook on situ
jito to d2 ah here you want to play rook
cd2 it's actually a good move and it
forces the move rook d3 according to the
engine
you would be fine there uh the better
try is um this is one try okay
but taking taking rook a2 is going to be
generally a good idea
in many positions agreed uh in this
particular one yeah rook cd2
forces a repetition because after roxy
in this position right another try for
white would be to give yourself the d
file
and it says that rook db3 actually is an
attempt why is this not a perpetual let
me check check rook d3 so you're still
kind of catching on and we've seen that
the move rookie two is not quite enough
in this variation rook takes g2 seems to
be enough
and that one is not so easy we're gonna
let richard analyze this as you can see
there's a very complicated series of
variations it is but someone that saw a
lot of variations and came out on top is
maxine bashar lagrave he is in bucharest
with christian
thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
here with uh the victor of today's round
one of the victors of today's round that
is uh maxim bashir lagrave maxine first
of all welcome back to the studio and
congratulations a big victory for you
against one of the toughest opponents in
the circuit tell us a bit about this
game and your feelings
as of right now um
yeah i mean as always when i play with
fabi we end up in big fights uh
mainly because
fabiano is a huge fighter always looks
for push up for sharp positions and i
generally do not back away from from the
fight as well
so this one this was one of those fights
um
it felt like uh he sort of surprised you
with this long d7 27
yeah i mean i know the two main moves
are bishop different queen g6 and queen
d7 isn't
against bishop e3 because 26 d6 the move
would be bishop e3
because bishop g4 would be answered by
bishop h7
king h8 queen e1
so
that's why queen d7
now would protect the bishops so the
bishop g4 stays protected so i was just
trying to to figure out why to play
because i am i mean i must have looked
at queen d7 obviously but it's not one
of the main moves and
um
and you came up with this move bishop g5
which makes a lot of sense one of the
things against bishop g4 because bishop
b3 but the problem of making engine
moves
i mean
is
that of course fabi was prepared against
it and and he immediately blitzed out
the uk yeah and especially after queen
d2 he bleeds out d4
were you worried at this point once he
played this move d4 i was not especially
concerned about my position especially
when
you know when phobia probably starts it
probably means that
i played the good move so
um
yeah i thought king gage shakes and was
interesting to be honest but
thumbs up it's not so great
but yeah uh so
g4
and here yeah maybe i
i mean maybe i went a bit too optimistic
also what i did is probably
correct but
yeah maybe a rocky one definitely seems
logical just trying to take advantage of
the light squares yeah okay one i guess
wha what was i scared about
i mean there was something and i just
hope my g3 is good
but i must say that i
here i
i mean here of course i could bail out
with queen g7
and
this is
this position how did you feel how did
you assess this position i felt it
should be holdable but
i mean i have two bishops i have passed
pawns where one it comes and also
black's pieces are a bit awkward for the
moment yeah
but it does feel like black is the one
at least with the initiative
and here yeah i must say that before i
saw and i was
a bit concerned about
which square to to put my queen and what
is the idea after going to c5 yeah
knight g4 knight to d4 yeah because 985
doesn't work anymore because of queen v5
which wins on the spot yeah this was it
so
uh
okay probably i'm
so not okay i didn't see bishop play for
let's say
uh
it seems like
i should be able to
i mean i wouldn't and we saw you
discussing also with fabiano at the end
did you guys discuss this particular no
we discussed what happened later later
on in the beginning because it was
definitely exciting so rockefeller came
as a
big surprise i must say it was even 94
before he played it or no i was
completely concerned about knight
different before so 94 i thought i'm
okay and then probably um and before i
was not completely sure uh also i must
say that yeah after before queen e3 like
d4
this would have been a bit less because
i realized later in the game after i
played all caps freeze that here this is
very strong take take your cafe yeah
because uh bishop to e4 because here if
i go shopping for
right so you guys got all the way and he
probably missed or at least that's what
we think that he missed bishop to d1 a
very good move after rook 2f4 a lot of
fun no but it's crazy no it's crazy
because here of course my plan was
bishop f2
but i was not 100 certain after bishop
p2 i take it takes
and so of course i'm better but
you know i thought there might be some
some tricks in storage so i thought kg2
is very clever and
because i saw queen h3 check i saw it
doesn't work and then fabio played okay
i mean i saw
i saw
after i played g2 that rook f4 was
i mean strong it turns out it's bad but
it looks very strong because bishop just
how bishop f2 was close to queen h3
excuse me
excuse me
but you did found the smooth bishop to
e1 yeah it came out of necessity and
what's lucky is that
it doesn't have a move
furby doesn't have a move here
and this is so strange but
after bishop d5 i just come back to g3
because the bishop isn't
an f1 and
yeah i couldn't find a way for him to
to keep the initiative so probably
and after queen f5 knight d2 is
e4 came on the board yeah after a very
long start and here
yeah i mean i've take c4 even works but
uh i just saw bishop g3f obviously
knight knight f3
again
queen to h3 yes
yeah
and bishop f3
well seems it's uh but anyways looking
f2 and this is just over and uh well big
victory for you congratulations davial
and we'll see you in the rest of your
games yeah thank you christian back to
you guys
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and
health and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized care
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
hello again and uh we continue with our
coverage of round four of the super pet
chess classic in bucharest mania
and uh what around we have
well we have two results uh in our
current standings as mbl has won a very
nice game uh indeed today uh peter and
he is currently uh as you can see on
your screen up top uh with uh bogdan
dayak they've played four rounds and
there's still a game on going between uh
wesley and yanni bom nishik which could
produce an outright leader if if wesley
converts his extra pawn
and
yeah sorry yeah and uh this is uh
a lot of people who were picked as our
predictions to win the tournament are
actually somewhat struggling fabiano
lost today which means he's a
point and a half out of four and minus
one
uh levon is uh also having a quiet
tournament but his one and a half points
is out of three and he's still playing
and has a very promising position
against lanier dominguez so he might
actually be
in with a share of the lead if he if he
wins and wesley doesn't whereas uh ali
raza and this is a very striking
striking shirt you have to say even by
levon standards this is quite something
you've got shark
week
the shirt should get more screen time
the shirt should have its own instagram
account well you just have to
go to cue boutique
shirt maybe it'll be good to get it for
a lot of pre-ordering going on i talked
to brian flowers about getting this very
relevant to chess world exactly exactly
i know now that we're back
how
clo how much progress has wesley made it
to me that he's like made a lot like
this is enormous amount of progress and
we might have a clear leader
it's possible you still have to ask
yourself
exactly what sort of the end result of
all this progress is you will get to
play a four and e5 it will require some
preparation currently f4 would be a
horrible horrible mistake because allows
queen b2 the queens come off and it's
once again immediately a draw correct
but of course white can avoid this by
starting with queen somewhere or king h3
i was thinking that queen h5 followed by
foreign i was thinking that
once a 495 lens
perhaps there is maybe some point in
putting our king on h5
just to take away some of
the additional squares
i'm just putting some moves on yeah yeah
let's go e5 here i think he could play
yeah it's the same yeah yeah we need 75.
so we get here yeah but it doesn't
really resolve
the big question of i mean it all looks
fantastic it does yeah as you as you as
you say yeah take a picture it's a it's
a fabulous fabulous position to look at
it still doesn't present you as as well
for white with a clear-cut way to to
actually land the this decisive blow you
get the pawn to e5 but the pontiffs on
f7 i mean the number of attackers and
the number of defenders is going to be
equal for the rest of the game black is
not going to blunder the f7 pawn right
and the king on g2 cannot really join
the attack on the f7 pawn your pawn
breaks have run out apart from e5 v6 g4
g5 is going to be pretty much always
going to be an improvement for black i
would say i would say
allowing a trade-off of one of the
weaknesses for a very healthy uh pawn on
g3 right a 405 weakens
probably lethally weakens the pawn of d5
so it's very rarely going to be playable
so you need to somehow find a way to
improve from a position like this and
this is where yeah like you can put even
even a king on h5 a kind of a an idea
very reminiscent of that
king to h4 maneuver wesley used to beat
uh shakhri arma mijara finally
one exactly but i'm not sure what it
does here like it's beautiful but what
does it do well
at a certain moment if i do get my king
to h5 and we get a position like this
where i've got some
what we might call a complete domination
at certain moment e5 e6 is yeah just
tend to cause a checkmating
exactly let's i mean we can actually get
there okay
let's analyze concretely
because i want to draw your attention
the fact that a move that i didn't
consider was good
was played
and it scares me for yan
because he just played it with bishop d4
and i'm wondering in this position
can you just start with e5 you can
keep up just cut that cut the ball cut
the bishop from the defense yeah that's
a scary scary idea because
if the coordination gets broken up you
lose right this is a kind of a position
where
passive defense is nice and i mean nice
as in uh
not nice and i understand his uh his
desire to keep his pieces somewhat
active but how do you even reply to e5
queen of three here just seems to end
the game checkmate because yeah let's
just put the a sample line of queen a7
bishop takes f7 at the very least yeah
at least you get the the queen ending
which is completely winning but i have a
feeling there might be some kind of a
mate which you would go for exactly yeah
bishop d4 looks like young just kind of
grew tired of not making it
out there and maybe yeah maybe you go e5
like king of
no king of fate queen of three is maybe
even wars
and maybe queen c7 here but yeah i
don't think this is great wow wow we
were a moment ago we were wondering how
on earth white could break through
now
only move not to resign in a few
pardon me e5 king f8 only move i i just
have a feeling that this might be might
be best because you need to sidestep
cringey for check tactics you just you
can't need to you can't leave the the
queen g4 tactics on the table but this
is horrible like queen of frequency 7 e6
f6 or something appears to be best play
but
you know this is not an improvement my
goodness this is not an improvement
yeah
i'll just give you the engine lines you
can look at it on your board sure uh
after the move e5 king f8 king f8 queen
f3 doesn't quite do the trick
unfortunately for white quincy black has
queen g6 correct this i missed yeah this
is a misconception and this just about
holds on to white's uh black's position
the problem is that after king f8
there's a very clever move queen e4
now you can't take on f2 because queen
five just picks up the bishop
and the point is that you're tethered
you're tethered right now to the defense
of the bishop to d4 and i'm gonna get my
queen either to f5 or i'm going to just
push e6
and with your king specifically on f8
it might just get mated or force you to
lose the h6 pawn both of which lose the
game
mm-hmm
yeah no queen e4 looks yeah 24 is a very
and i think like a hawk you can see that
wesley he's been maneuvering for a while
but he says bishop d4 and he's like wait
a second
wait a second
and he's reaching for it
he's reaching for e5 there it is
e5 you're getting serious problems here
oh my goodness yeah this is uh this is
not good for for young at all during our
break uh alejandro we were talking about
wesley and we seem to
we we both have the same impression that
you know if he starts well oh yeah he
has this uh
approach that says okay i'm shutting
things down i'm gonna play very very
solid from now on i'm gonna close to my
plus one plus two result and then it's
his opponents seem to self-destruct yes
absolutely i've seen it so many times it
happened i think it was in the london
chess classic in 2016 the first time
that uh
wesley won the gct he was playing
against hikaru i think wesley was
already on plus one and hikaru just
destroyed his own position by 18 moves
with white and wesley just won easily
and at that time he was plus two and
just
cruised to victory right
and you were mentioning at the start uh
peter that nepo actually has a bad
result
yeah uh
individual match-ups with wesley yeah
well wesley definitely is uh you know
what is uh known as an awkward opponent
for
for jan i think this is also kind of
playing into what we're seeing today
i i get the feeling that there might be
a very simple kind of a
explanation to what happened today
in very in very simple chess terms
similar to what we heard uh shahriar say
in an interview i think
it's it's extremely possible that jan
just mixed up the move order he kind of
remembered that both knight takes e3 and
knight c2 happened
and much earlier in the enemy and uh
and he forgot which one goes first and
he ended up moving having yeah having to
defend a position he did not want to
defend because it's very difficult for
me to imagine that
this actually was the the world
championship prep against magnus because
yeah like
wesley
wesley i think is a kind of a close
number too you don't want on the white
side here but i mean magnus is probably
very easily number one very clear number
one in the list of people you absolutely
want any other position against like any
other position just not this one uh so
strange perhaps yeah i i do get the
feeling that uh
he just
decided not to triple check which order
those moves come in and
drifted into having to defend this
and uh kind of hated life
ever since and the fact that it's wesley
on the opposite side was not helping at
any point obviously
no for
for shaq by the way i believe uh
defending champion he won with a plus
three
uh no losses uh for shaq last year no
losses i believe he beat fabi with the
black pieces in spanish he beat
lupulesco in a crazy game and blanking
out who he beat as well
but it was a 12 person round-robin no
it was ten
it was ten same uh
a very very similar field dude
no no no no no he's played queen jesus
which looks logical but apparently is a
very poor move i kind of wonder why
there has to be some kind of a very
simple practical refutation
yeah i mean king takes queen
c4 check is an easy pick up uh double
attack and two pawns up
who managed to draw two pawns down and a
queen ending
that was that was lavon against
linearity that was just unbelievable not
this one and the other one he at least
had a pass pawn counter play kind of
position but this one is just
terrible not three against one as we as
we by this point know some two against
zero are actually drawn but not three
against one and not
not g uh f and e against h yeah i think
i think probably f and g against zero
also not drawn i think it's specifically
g h because of how little hiding space
you have on the board yeah yeah but the
bishop f7 is a actually a rather easy
tactic it's a
double double check
a double attack sorry double check
yeah
wow yeah we will we'll wait for for
wesley to spot it because uh if if it
didn't exist
this would become
borderline holdable like if you give
like a tempo here to somehow consolidate
they play queen five or
uh queen of five actually still has
bishop x7 uh maybe king g7 i think
seven also allows version
right i was i was gonna say if you don't
see the tactic bishop takes f7 um how
good or bad would you evaluate f2f4 i
would still i would still read it yeah
but there it is there's no doubt that
going to see this
simple tactic i think i think he saw
cringey six when he played e5 i think i
think he saw it in advance yeah and uh
and do we expect
uh this is an absolute disaster yes i
think a very very disgusted young is
going to show up at the board and just
resign yeah exactly because yeah i mean
you can play on but it's completely
hopeless and also you just sit there
hating life so much that why would you
do this to yourself well as levon
revealed we were wondering he what he
thought about for 50 minutes in his game
against uh farouja
and gary said oh he's cursing himself
it was a confirmation yeah we did we did
get immediate information
he's not going to be hating life today
he is cruising through victory in this
one which is extra pawn better
pieces and yeah yeah this will be very
easy for him
yeah i think the the cleanest way to win
here would be to play c4 c3 the white
king gets to d3 and then you prepare it
when you play c3 c2 king takes you
looking e4
and then you pick up the pawn on g3 and
you win the nice thing about it is you
don't have to prepare it right you're
just subscribed yeah it's just the very
first you can you can actually even just
pass for it you can just possibly right
no but i i get king d3 e3 so i mean
eventually i mean the c pawn will have
to be sacrificed but it's just such an
easy sacrifice you play bishop f5 here
king e3 you go c2 i know can you three
bishop g3 ah no it doesn't work i was
lying i'm lying then i don't need to
discovering c1 yeah just just go c2 and
yeah this just looks cute but actually
kind of might throw the game completely
let me show alejandro
alejandro yeah
it was a very nice tax thank you great
combination thank you but uh
what you had said earlier was absolutely
spot-on
this is just for so easy suddenly
i mean actually king of three and take
on g3 immediately to have king g4 after
94 check
this might be somewhat relevant actually
not to give up the pawn on the f5
um and then we collect we collect the
entire king side and the two coins win
very very easily against none exactly
exactly
wow if we're watching something in the
playing hall we should probably be
watching the uh the the sony bom nishi
board yeah
and there is the handshake
as wesley so
wow um
plus two it's a gct dream start for the
defending champion plus two off the
gates sort of four games playing
solicits never being worse two opposite
color bishop end games in which he's
pressing the entire game both of his
opponent is cracking under pressure
right and he just cruises to plus two
no
we we we've spoken about this we're our
top players are so close in terms of
their ratings that you know fabi losing
today
wesley winning levon
winning uh do you want to know how it
matches up yeah i'll look it up just uh
just to
uh i don't know
our olympic team is always in this
constant state of flight speeder and
this is where we stand thanks to
wesley's victory here
absolutely wesley will be the outright
leader after this round he is on plus
two uh the two names following him are
on plus one and there might be one more
player on plus one if lee won as we
expect converts his overwhelming
advantage against lanier even though i'm
honestly kind of shocked by the
uh the method he chose to to continue
from that position i assume it's still
winning i assume he calculated it out
but i really don't know why you would
give yeah i mean it's not on the wall
it's not on the screen i'll wait until
it's on the screen so the standings are
there's still nobody on minus two
but there's a number of people on minus
one
and uh wesley is the only one on plus
two so he will lead the tournament
outright two games remaining levon we
expect will win his
and to answer your question yasser
wesley actually moves on to number five
in the world he's still behind fabi but
only by 3.3 points which is
a very very very close affair yeah
exactly and because of ramadan's
performance here
america now
has uh 40 of the top 10
uh chess players as hikaru enters the
top ten since my media have left it wow
go america
olympiad in chennai
now uh peter with the way our olympic
team works is basically a ratings
formula
you've got this rating for me a lot of
teams around the world are chosen by
selection committee
uh how does it work in russia
it is it is pretty i mean ratings
obviously come into it but it has never
been set in stone exactly who gets in
huge i mean sometimes i would guess most
times
the reigning national champion gets a
spot on the team even though there have
been there have been exceptions uh and
this is how i first got onto the team
and i think i'm pretty sure they
regretted it because uh
the the first time the russian
championship was held with enough prize
money to attract most of the uh
players but nowhere near all of the top
players
that was in 1994 and they made a mistake
of actually writing it into the
regulations for the tournament that the
winner will get a team on the olympic
team uh and yeah i won that and i was
really i mean i would be the first one
to say i was nowhere near already right
but they kind of card committed
themselves yeah they had they had no way
out so they did they just have to get me
on nicely
yeah they did put me on the team and um
i i did okay at the olympiad i i played
board six i didn't really ruin anything
but there were clearly players and who
were much more deserving
uh but yeah it's it's it's a selection
process which is uh a lot of t a lot of
uh
countries a lot of teams from various
countries use the national championship
to at least pick one
uh and uh this is a total prize fund
breakdown for the tour in general in
2022 and you can see
there is a trifidi as i mentioned
earlier uh for the classical events and
175
uh thousand dollars for the rapid and
blitz tournaments uh so
uh
twice as much money for classical uh
putting a lot of
weight
on those tournaments and a nice bonus uh
placement money too that's why they play
for those grand chess tour points as
another felt
100 000
uh bonus prize for the player who is the
most successful in the torpedo
absolutely ever the gct continues being
uh very much a
flagship flagship series
and let's jump to bucharest as we have a
very
happy
tournament leader with a christian
thank you yasser yes we are indeed here
with wesley first of all wesley big
congratulations that's a huge victory
against one of the co-leader going into
this round they take us to your strategy
going into this game how did you
approach it well
uh
ian is
very strong he's the challenger
obviously i mean he didn't
i think he
did very great play in order to qualify
for the world championship match so i
have a huge a lot of respect for him
and uh
i just want to play a normal game see
what happens i mean it's
not easy to get advantage or win these
days also he has great preparation but
you went back to your beloved catalan
now with the white pieces
and uh did he surprise you at all with
his opening choice this pawn sacrifice
well the actually
the reason why i played the catalan is
because i was inspired by
fabiano who played against me yesterday
so i think it makes sense to
copy your opponent's openings for the
other side sometimes just to get more
familiarity so that's the only reason
why
i played the catalan but uh
obviously
ian prepared this variation in the match
and uh he's
he's very well prepared you know like
i
actually are opening followed the
game by anish geary and uh
i mean of course i didn't expect to win
like i was just slightly better for the
most part
but
winning is a huge deal and uh just to
stop you for a second levon actually has
won oh yeah his game against lanier big
victory for uh levon as well let's get
back yeah let's get back to your game
winning with the black pieces it's huge
yes almost impossible this level yeah
impossible and you guys played quite
quickly all the way up to uh somewhere
this point and he was still playing
finding this uh almost only moves quite
quickly this move h6 is very good
he actually played this before with
black like anis
oh really i think anish geary was white
no i'm sure
but i think it's a blitz game okay in
the world blitz okay a few months back
so he played this and uh
i mean i thought
i mean computers showing closer equality
at all times but i thought black is
still pawn down so and you are still
playing quite confidently uh at this
point you are still within your
preparation more or less yeah until
queen h4 you got it yeah when a5 was the
computer but basically i think uh
if black can trade queens then he should
hold the end game quite easily so white
has to try to keep queens maybe maybe r8
was not the best maybe like bishop f6
and then the point is queen f for some
queen b8 like i can change
the queens yeah take take e3 bishop f3
and i think black holds this
but of course i mean it's not it's still
going to be some pressure yeah i thought
this is not according to ian's style of
play was very aggressive to defend the
pawn down so i thought it's worth a try
at the very least i didn't see full
equipment no i want to ask you something
about this particular endgame this
variation in a lot of sub-variations you
end up in the same game did you look at
it uh at all at home
sorry not before the game but maybe in
previous months in this this exact
ending yes this structure
yeah i mean
why this upon up but i it's objectively
a draw i mean
i
think
players would be happy to get this
slight advantage these days but
i mean there's not much to analyze and
basically black puts this through from
the second rank and just place g6 h5
uh so but still do
you think there's some ideas yeah it
seems weird because black has many other
good lines and to go straight from the
opening
but actually this slide is becoming very
famous this b5 blind like
the pawn sacrifice yeah that's the
players in playing nakamura has been
playing it also like he plays it all the
time so
i know that sure my student also tried
it once and uh it didn't work out very
well for him so
yeah i know it's very unpleasant maybe
bishop takes here is also interesting
bishop taking photoshop
yeah so that way you keep some pressure
on the default but got it i mean it's uh
theoretical opening so let's let's go
to this situation once you guys simplify
the position a little bit he started
shaking his head and then took on f
really yeah like after queen g4
i think he thought for like 30 minutes
here on this position
yeah i mean he i guess he realizes just
fall down yeah and then he went for this
but i mean
with without the queens on board it's a
draw but with the queen's some chances
okay so when did you feel like you got
some extra chances yeah i win this one
and getting closer to a victory i mean i
felt i want to keep the rooks but i
couldn't really find a way to make it
work because you always agree with it
too
so i mean of course i want to play this
but uh here i started shuffling move
because i'm gonna like i couldn't find a
way to
make progress increase the pressure on
f7 yeah like i was considering some g4
but i think e4 f4 is better g4 probably
weakens the king too much and then all
sorts of perpetuals yes yeah it begins a
dark square but i was
i wasn't sure how to win here if you
just wave squid at six i think i have to
go e4 f4 at some point
and it's unless and i was surprised when
he played g6 i mean of course it's still
a draw do you feel he just lost patience
at this point uh
no psychologically how did you feel him
at this point when he played this move
g6 i thought he was very confident at
first but then he started thinking using
up sometime from like 20 minutes and i
think he saw some ghosts so
that's why he played g6 but i thought
his black weights queen at six i don't
know just keep waiting it's not so easy
to make progress maybe it's better for
black just to wait then i have to go e4
and this one uh the game that we're
seeing right now between first and
report did
end up in a draw right now they're
repeating the position so all the
gameplay work all the games are finished
we're going to go back to uh your
analysis wesley
four nights four nights very very
possibly absolutely so it did seem like
at this point already you were starting
to pressure him quite unpleasantly uh
and he played this move bishop to d4
did you understand that this move loses
yeah i was very surprised when he played
this because i started calculating some
lines and i think the bishop is
misplaced his king is under pressure to
beat up d4 i guess was the losing
blunder
but uh
i mean i think ian also didn't
particularly like this position i think
objectively is still a draw but if i get
e5 and queen d7
like
coin f6 let's say i don't know maybe
black has a
lot of better ways but i was hoping to
get this position something like this
and then bring my queen over to i don't
know d7
yeah maybe i wasn't sure it's already
starting to get unpleasant absolutely
yeah i mean i was hoping to get
something like this queen f5 and maybe
you can set up the battery to give a
checkmate a 1b1 queen f5 you know yeah
bring my king to h5 because many many
end games are actually winning for white
sometimes when i win a second point even
uh the bishop and game
if he tries to go some queen to e6 and
exchange it over there yeah exactly when
yeah i mean something like this looks
very bad for
for black i mean i was hoping for
something like this
reminds me of your game against track
just walk the king of the board yeah i'm
sure the computer will draw this quite
easily but
for humans
it's not also you're like suffering like
one dog you don't really want to
keep playing wesley
thank you very much plus to a big
victory today how do you feel about the
tournament so far and what makes you
play so well here in bucharest
yeah i think i mean
yeah i mean leading them but
uh obviously i like to thank the lord
for always come from him also thank my
mom and people saying that also yeah
thank you christian for you always very
cheerful here you seem to appreciate
that yeah you seem to bring me very good
luck and uh yeah you're always friendly
and cheerful and uh
i'm just satisfied i can still win games
after the horrible torment st louise
like
can understand it sometimes i play well
sometimes i play horribly horrible but
it seems i always need the horrible
tournament to play well like
i just
need a lot of focus but uh
uh it's uh it's nice when you're winning
people are friendly well after this
point this is definitely
your tournament keep the spirits up keep
the energy up and we'll see you in the
rest of your games yeah one one game at
a time i mean absolutely
guys back to you thank you uh christian
and again our congratulations to wesley
on his victory
and you're watching something quite rare
actually because the threefold
repetition is not straight up the same
moves all the time they actually went to
a different board and richie showed to
the arbiter of the repeated position and
that it will occur the third time if he
goes through kc2 and you do have to
check when it's when it's not just the
same you know bishop bishop of firebish
before five [ __ ] before i thought it
was the arbiter that goes through the
move nor actually yes it's not the
players yeah
i'm used to seeing the arbiter sitting
there richie richie took control of that
yeah uh and uh yeah the game the game is
a draw which concludes our round with uh
three decisive games out of five today
absolutely yeah
uh we've been having one victory per
round only but uh
alejandro uh
this round four was extraordinary
wins that means nobody is on four draws
now we have everybody at least with one
decisive result and wesley with two wins
finds himself at the top of the
leaderboard levonnaroni and i have to
say after his position yesterday i would
not have expected him to reach two and a
half out of four but there he is up
there with bogdan daniel dayak playing
very well in this tournament so far and
an mvl
that said i don't shy away from a fight
you wanna you wanna fight come here you
can sacrifice as many pieces as you want
i can
calculate very well and finds himself
also tied for second great round today
we have yeah and we find a great rounds
here every day absolutely interestingly
they're straight in the middle of the uh
the standings there is the animation who
actually had two decisive games the only
one the only one on 50 percent of the
four rounds right uh so a very very
interesting situation with wesley of
course isn't very pretty up up top there
on plus two obviously
enjoying his time in bucharest
well again a very eventful round uh i
just at the very end here the it just
did seem to be a lot of twoing and
throwing and
whenever
richie was asked a sailing in question
he wasn't he answered it precisely yeah
he certainly did that was exactly what i
wanted to say yes another yet another
facet of his play you know we've seen
him play crazy crazy tactical games but
he defended the somewhat unpleasant
technique well i mean not that technical
but still uh it's a rook ending it's a
whole different you know kettle of fish
compared to some of his previous uh
efforts and
after the time control he made a
sequence of very very precise decisions
and the one i'm very sort of uh
impressed by uh looking at your screen
here yasser yes is that he played rook's
ec2
on move 40.
and that's also a sign of somebody who
trusts in his chess abilities right now
i think i think he kind of knows he's
playing well because i don't think he
got that much time yeah and on move 41
it's a decision you take reasonably
comfortably you you know you you get up
you get yourself a beverage you
you chilled
uh for a bit and calculate but on move
40 it's a very very committal decision
if it backfires you probably lose
exactly and yeah he calculated clearly
enough and trusted in his calculation uh
well enough to go for it on 40.
exactly
well let's jump uh once again to
bucharest romania as we have christian
with lavon
thank you yasser we are with a very
happy levon aronia lavon yesterday you
had this houdini-like escape it almost
emboldened you to go for a victory today
also you're wearing this nice shark
themed shirt tell us a bit about this oh
how did you choose it well it's annie
who got this shirt shirt for me and she
said uh i told her that uh you know it's
maybe
maybe it's not a good idea to wear it
and maybe it's destructive to my
opponents and but it's a beautiful shirt
so
i have it for like three tournaments
already but today i was
she finally convinced me to wear it
important maybe by yesterday's game for
sure yeah i thought you know generally
people are very friendly here and
i don't think the arbiter will come and
complain why not absolutely let's go
through today's game did he surprise you
at all in the opening or who do you feel
like won the opening stage of this game
i think i surprised him more because
this a5 move is very tricky and uh here
he started thinking taking some time f45
a5 a5 yeah number eight
and then uh yeah because
well
main line is 94 we should be 6 knight c3
which is very challenging
and then you have
a bit of crazy complications starting
with bishop e6
and we're not going to question you too
much about that because obviously yes
knight c3 queen h5 92 check and
sometimes just to start yeah that's just
the start
okay we're not going to get into that
and he played he shied away from that he
played the move
away and i thought f6 is precise this is
what i remember that this is more or
less equal in d4 yeah okay through three
one mm-hmm came to h8 take on d4 and now
you get this
iqp yeah i thought bishop f5 is a normal
move like during the game i didn't
remember what i have analyzed but i
thought bishop a5 a3 then some rookie
this should be kind of normal for black
i thought that 27 and i get this active
play with rookie 8 bishop b4 should be
enough compensation for the two bishops
yeah i think
it should be around echo
and then he played this move knight to a
g3 yeah which kind of looked interesting
and uh
yeah
i knew that i could maybe play uh 97
here you know without
needing to play rook e8 but somehow i
thought
you know it doesn't
hurt just to
get there slowly
exchange one more piece so maybe it was
imprecise
and at this point also anastasia was
making the point that you were trying to
rope your uh opponent into some sort of
false sense of a security was that your
thought process as well
no not really i was just trying you know
calculating trying not to make the
mistakes that i did in the previous
round by you know playing too fast
i thought uh
spent some time and when we got this
position
i mean uh
well i've analyzed the
i mean starting with 97 you know of
course i have this other moves
knight c7 and or i don't have to take on
f5 of course
i can't play knight d5 of course it's
easier to play with black especially
when my opponent was down
but i was very tempted you know just to
kind of provoke him because i thought
that
okay night before i saw this queen f3
that is making a draw but
i mean this rook d1 ideas but then i was
uh
you know kind of uh
telling myself this is so difficult to
see because you know your rook is on the
open file yeah
i mean it seems like you should be
striking there right instead of bringing
it back bring it back on the d file yeah
yeah so this is my hope and i think my
hope
paid off paid off
and i got a good position maybe i didn't
play the most precise way
but uh i i don't think i've missed uh
you know a win
or needed win so i i think i was always
in control yeah absolutely and you ended
up in this winning endgame which you
converted easily levon how would you
assess your performance after this point
very shaky but today was a good game
perfect thank you very much for joining
us we'll see you in the rest of your
games thanks guys back to you thank you
lavon love the shirt love the game uh
let's take a look at our standings peter
with all the games done in this round
four yeah and yeah once again this is
the standings wesley clear first here
with two very very nice smooth victories
in opposite color bishop endings live on
mbl and bogdan de aircon plus one uh
with three draws in one victory
yanipamishi made two jaws 1-1 and lost
one and then we have a bunch of people
died for either sixth or last whichever
whichever way you wanna you wanna sixth
time
it just sounds nicer yeah all of them
all of them losing one game and drawing
the remaining three
and uh as we look at our schedule going
ahead we have one more
game and then tuesday is our estate
absolutely yeah and uh the whole
discussion of whether players are more
inclined or less inclined to be
combative on on on in the round before
the rest day can be saved until tomorrow
exactly i've always felt that uh on the
day before the rest day i give it my all
because i know i've got this extra rest
day so i tend to i think that's a
prevailing opinion but i'm not sure if
it's borne out by facts you know we need
more statistics
we get a lot of decisive games like we
had today uh
uh alejandro but first our predictions
let's see how we're doing we're doing
this is not necessary to look at any of
these predictions
uh so that's me
that'd be disappointing var
is doing
virus var is doing really really well
everybody else is on minus one out of
our prediction my guy's in sixth place
yeah
i don't know about you guys so it's mine
but lara is doing exceedingly well so
far
and uh let's jump to romania for uh some
final thoughts
well uh what a day guys uh three
decisive results uh i actually lost my
voice because of it but what an amazing
day this was even that uh game that
finished in a draw between bogdan daniel
and mamedyarov could have swung in
either way so we're having a lot of very
fun exciting and fighting chess and uh
we love to do uh casting on that type of
chess how about yourself anastasia yeah
absolutely we agree with you christian
actually i was asking for more decisive
results and here we are three decisive
games after first three rounds and of
course all the games deserve a lot of
attention and those who missed something
you should definitely go and check
everything also it was nice to see once
again the world champion here in the
studio gary casparo came again and
shared his thoughts with us and
overall it was great day and i'm really
looking forward to see the moral of the
game between wesley saw and leonardo the
winners of today and also i was actually
quite interested in the results in the
game of levon because he he managed to
escape in the previous day and i was
just kind of asking myself is it just a
luck for one game or he will push his
luck again and actually he is doing well
it looks like so christian are you happy
about the day today oh absolutely and
i'm definitely looking forward to
tomorrow's round because tomorrow is the
day before the rest day and we know how
bloody those type of rounds usually get
today we we got three decisive results
let's see what it brings on tomorrow
guys back to you thank you anastasia and
a christian and final thoughts uh
alejandro it was a great day three
decisive results that just speak for
themselves and as christian mentioned
the deck mamadiara game could have gone
either way and we had a candidates
matchup between farouzia and rapport
that really left nothing on the tape off
the table we had a theoretical duel
calculations an end game that was
extremely sharp and it was a well played
game from beginning to end so it was a
great day if you look at it from it just
chest wise and i'm happy to cast it
absolutely combined with a very unusual
opening this 94 king
looking opening let's put it like this
because these days everything is theory
well put thank you everyone for joining
us join us tomorrow same time same
channels we'll be giving we'll be
bringing you round five of
the grand chess tour
stay tuned or
see you tomorrow see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you